I'm here.
Okay, I'm here, guys.
Wow, we made it just in time.
I'm here.
Look, they said 430.
It's a pre-warm-up.
I, this is a live.
Okay, that is a live.
What the fuck?
They said the main show is at 5.
So I was like, oh, it's 30 minutes.
I have enough to, sorry, I was eating.
I have enough time for this.
I could be a little bit late.
I didn't realize they're going straight into trailers right
off the bat.
Anyway, let me write that I'm here.
Live now.
I am here, guys.
I am here.
All right, sound guy.
Whenever you're ready, let me know in Discord if everything
is fine.
Yes, I had my tooth extraction.
Um, so I hope I didn't fuck up my, my, my socket.
I hope I don't get a dry socket.
Miss family game.
Okay.
You can bring it up.
Alright, don't worry, I've got you.
I mean, bring it up here.
Of course, the Nintendo payment went through.
on behalf of all of us at nintendo and especially what the
fuck that was so fast how did they get here so fast how it's
like he it's like he already knew he just is like he got
there in like one second yeah dgb how did he get here he
just knew he knows why i told you the payment went through
bro was ready looks like smashing things is kind of thank
you very much bro no that that's a teleprompter right there
yeah you're spot-capping the rewards all right i upped it up
a bit more in sweden who's a hardcore souls fan he's built a
cat girl there you go to twitch brad i'm thinking thank you
but yes i am back i thought i could talk a little bit but
before we go straight into it.
But I guess not.
There's like no time to chill.
What the fuck is warm up then?
It was like 4.30 is the pre-show.
Like I'm like, then what the fuck does pre-show mean if it's
the actual show?
Like that's not pre-show.
Like you can't just put trailers in the pre-show.
Like what the fuck is the difference between pre-show?
like oh your trailers aren't aren't as good we're putting
you in the pre-show they don't they said five is the they
said five was the main show and the 430 is the pre-show so i
just assume it's just gonna be like people just talking and
like being like what do you think or like interview the red
or is there red carpet in the game awards i don't know but
you know what i mean like i'm like are these like is the
pre-show for the people who didn't pay a million dollars for
their fucking trailers to show sorry they paid 500 000 not
good enough
sorry they were only able to afford 500k instead of a
million dollars you're in the pre-show yeah yeah for those
who don't know um so you just have to pay a million dollars
to be shown their trailer on to have the trailer shown it's
literally like the super bowl i keep saying this is people
were like don't don't support the game awards and i'm like
um it's dog shit i'm like i don't care about who the fuck
wins i'm just here for the trailer like the super bowl like
i think like like a lot of people here we're just here for
the trailers who's here for the actual awards part of the
award show this is really the super bowl for gamers
yeah and the thing is at least it's cheaper than a super
bowl ad like
it's at least cheaper than a super bowl ad guys yeah i like
the trailers that's where they always put all the world
premieres the game from dylan fitter the creator of I don't
understand people who like subscribe to the game awards like
your five dollars It is going it is not you want to give
Jeff five dollars Showcase tonight.
We made it easy for you.
Check out the game awards page on steam.
All right audio people Okay, I have to bring it more.
Okay, I'll bring up more Jeff does not need the money guys
if Jeff is like definitely does not need the oh wait the
category is the game awards mom can you change my categories
i didn't even realize they have their own category guys
actually i can i can change it here let me change it here i
didn't even realize they have their own category game awards
don't worry i got it all right done fc26 and south of
midnight the game award goes to there's no time to do a
prediction for this doom the dark ages innovation
inaccessibility what's the innovation thank you so much this
is such a such an honor i assume that's more like colorblind
yeah this with uh the idea of creating doom for all slayers
a doom for all slayers and we couldn't be more proud of the
team is that more so for people who are their commitment to
accessibility and the support of the game and as well as I
don't know what else they have Zenimax user research you
know how like um our accessibility you know how when you get
your tooth extracted you're like you're supposed to eat like
soft food for the for the next week um I had sandwich for
dinner I was eating a sandwich for a day I was just craving
a sandwich I was like I'm yum yum know it was definitely not
stop oh yeah miss piggy's here that's crazy i wonder what
what the fuck is she presenting all right it has to be a
child's game all right i opted a little bit more sound guys
immerse yourself in a realm of magic mystery and boundless
adventure into this mess food will get me out of it only
food can comfort me okay this is gonna sound really mean but
i understand why these trailers weren't put on the main show
sorry i'm sorry
i know now i know what
Okay, up some more.
Alright, let's see.
Guild Wars 2.
Oh!
I know this game.
We played it on stream.
Duck off.
I think a lot of these games are like already released too,
right?
It's just to be like, hey guys, check out this already
released game.
I wonder how much... I wonder how much I...
to pay for the pre-show trailers.
Oh yeah, I love Jeff's tweet and he's like, guys, there
might be game trailers releasing today.
I'm like, oh shit.
Oh my god, great news.
Holy fuck, guys, did you hear?
Jeff says maybe today there will be game trailers.
No fucking way.
I don't know, they even Twitch Prime, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the gifted sub.
Big.
Thank you for the tier one subs.
Sorry if I missed your subs, guys.
I'm really sad, but thank you guys so much for all the subs.
I signed an NDA, but I'm going to risk it all just for you.
So, here's a hint about what's coming up.
Speaking of NDAs, there will be lots of new game
announcements.
The devs was like, the rival's devs messaged me and was
like, you should check out the game awards because we have a
special announcement and i was like oh shit really what is
it and then the dev the dev was like we can't tell you i'm
like come on give me a hint and then and then the dev was
like girl i signed an nba with disney just wait
so i don't know so i don't know what is it But there's
apparently a special announcement for rivals.
Yeah, and they're not risking it for me I was like, oh, I
just want little in and she pulled out the Disney card And
the game award goes to game isn't that like CS two I'm also
who invited mobile legends bang bang?
Not wait not Faker?
Who are these people?
And the game award goes to?
Cho-V!
Yeah, where's Faker?
I'm surprised Faker didn't get in.
Yeah, but also I would thought League would have League
because of the finals.
Wasn't there more people watching the League finals though?
Team Fatality.
Which were...
What team was that?
Which game was that?
Around the world on more than 30 platforms.
Including for the first time on Prime Video.
Um...
Wasn't there more people watching the League Finals than
there were for CS?
That's why I thought like me Um, you would win it.
Also Mobile Legends Bang Bang.
Like what is that?
I know mobile gaming has a lot of fans, though.
Especially in Asia.
Oh, yeah, we saw this trailer.
Yeah,
I was going to say.
Mobile Bang Bang must have been really popular in Asia.
I've never heard of it, though.
But I know mobile gaming in general is popular in Asia.
Oh, Major League, Mobile League, Bang Bang.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
No, this is a...
We've seen trailers for this game for a while.
It's just like, yeah.
I think it's extraction.
Is it extraction shooter?
No, it's a single player.
I'm sorry.
Every game... I feel like everyone's just coming up with
extraction shooters now.
Every time I see a gun, I'm like, is that an extraction
shooter?
you're like it's like last year where every game was either
in space or post-apocalyptic now it's just like is this an
extraction shooter it's the new meta
coming later of the same beach in my research station back
home and surprise you can play a demo of pragmata on steam
right now see apparently do a thing where like we can add
ourselves to the the viewer account but like i don't know
how to do that i'm not good i don't think it really does
anything anyway like the watch along coach like the
co-stream thing i don't even know what how to do that oh
mobile game destiny rising i'll be surprised if uma uma
musume didn't win um
Umah?
Umah what?
Umah Musume!
It is a tremendous honor to receive this amazing I'm not
surprised it was only possible with support of our fans.
I deeply appreciate all the they knew these guys knew
already that they won they literally like lined them up to
the people who are not familiar with science we are
dedicated to being the best entertainment we will
prominently see okay i'm gonna up more sound guy i'm upping
it more let me know thank you yeah there has to be a lot for
all the winners and then the nominees are the other nominees
were like i hope i get announced not knowing that there's a
fucking line it's professional development and my adhd but
there so much more to come including two brand new game
announcements from two brand new game studios right after
this
oh tactical i write this letter to you as testimony new game
yeah but this is a pre-show trailer so my beloved you will
honor our goddess more than i they're not on the top bin
ricard my cherished find your father's steel and face the
challenges head what happened she knew mariko was coming for
her never forget the bonds that tie the six of you will be
your strength this is the actual show they like oh my god
they fucking lie to me then because they were like 5 p.m is
the main show she deserves the peace of death i literally
googled that what an interesting family you must have
Joki discriminating games.
I don't discriminate games because they're on the pre-show
trailer.
I discriminate games because I saw a tactical adventure.
I saw the word tactical.
War, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
So last, uh, two.
What's this?
I
was a sound guy.
I upped it up a lot more.
Let me know if I should up it more.
There's World of Tanks.
New DLC.
That's the only tank game I know.
Okay, I can up it more.
Oh,
it's like you can customize your own tank.
Oh, you can customize your own tank.
Oh, you can like you can like take their tank's body tank
rat that's interesting you kill the tank and then consume it
and then now it's your tank to the top of the hour everybody
go tell your friends to tune in and get ready see i told you
this is a pre-show i'm trying not to be too i'm trying not
to be too aggressive today because i don't want to pop my my
socket but now it's time to honor another leave but i'm
trying i'm trying to be a bit calm this year there have been
so many incredible independent titles from i told you i told
you this was a free show
they're trying to rage bait me ball pit best independent
games clear obscure expedition 33.
i feel I never played Claire, but I saw so many Blazing
Claire Yeah, I was gonna say it has to be Claire That's
crazy that the Indie game, it doesn't consider Top Bill for
the main show That's crazy They put the best Indie game In
the pre-show That's what they think about us Just for us
painting the walls Of the small office we had just rented We
wanted to make a small game then But with big and creative
independence.
It was challenging every day for most of our team present
here tonight.
Expedition 33 is the first game we've ever shipped.
That's crazy for the first game.
We couldn't be prouder of what this team has achieved and we
dedicate this award to all the indie teams around the world.
I like how he wore a beret to up the Frenchness.
He was like, yes, we are French.
to those who bring extraordinary lives to life every year.
You make our art form richer and you continue to inspire
generations of creators and players.
Thank you.
Unskilled.
Thank you, Latouche Prime.
Thank you.
Speaking of independent teams, this next game is a special
one.
They're so French, bro.
A brand new independent studio.
It comes from Day for Night, a new studio from the lead
designer of Red Dead Redemption and the creative director.
Okay, that...
And then Mario slash rabbit.
Okay, what a game catalog.
Rabbits and Red Dead Redemption.
Okay, that's a crazy catalog.
Yeah, what the fuck do you mean?
I love the new game.
All right, sound guy, I upped it more.
Let me know if I should up it even more.
Check.
Time for a new puck.
And that's a badger.
What the fuck?
All I wanted was to go back home.
Badger boys.
Exploring.
Did some jumping around.
You know.
The classic.
Oh.
What?
Everyone went look strange and weirdly...
Waiting for review.
Oh, wait.
This is interesting.
Interesting
Guys, we're getting blood.
Is this bloodboard too?
What the fuck?
This is interesting cyber badger.
Oh, he's jumping through games.
Oh Made a bunch of new friends It's like Oh!
That's interesting.
That's very meta.
I like this concept.
Docs?
Oh my god, what?
Immersion break, yeah.
And that's when I found you.
Bradley the badger.
Okay, that's...
actually this is an interesting concept okay so i always as
long as it's not a vr game chatbots that achieve sentience
first but i'm now an animated badger singularity and yes
that is actor evan peters playing the role of bradley the
badger who i have one more world wait who it comes from the
incredible brand new studio i'm missing tracks of the actors
man there's too many actors new world coming in 2026 and
we're excited to share the announcement who the fuck was the
oh oh the quick silver man oh which quick silver though
which one there's there's like three of them
oh it's this game featuring zombie davy and human julia
oh is this like the zombie move game
What is this?
Like, a rhythm game?
Like, what the fuck is this?
Where's the gameplay?
I'm just watching a music video.
Games don't need games.
But this is the game.
This is just a very long cutscene.
Yeah, I'm gonna say is this a warm body?
Is that fucking zombie?
Romance movie?
All right,
I'll put a little bit more sound.
Yeah, let me know.
All right, this one.
I'll put it more.
But that's studio.
I can't even read this.
The title isn't even like the suit.
Stupid, okay, whatever.
Stupid never dies.
Okay.
I can't read it!
It's in different fonts!
Okay, there's the gameplay.
I don't know.
I will say...
I don't eat humans.
Oh, stupid.
Okay, stupid never dies.
At some point, I thought that's a toop.
Toop never dies.
I don't know, that doesn't, I don't know, it doesn't look
that fun.
Good music though, good music, but the gameplay looks very,
a bit boring.
It looks very boring.
Action games for action game fans.
Okay, we're minutes away from the main event.
We have one more award for you, a category that celebrates
other media.
I like the Badger one.
The Badger one is really interesting.
I like how it's like it's very meta.
Quarantine, Miki, they give a tier one something.
Thank you.
The fact that the Sonic movie isn't in here is a fucking
crime.
Like three of these movies, fucking soft.
Like until Dodd, really?
The Last of Us season two.
Aww.
i mean they didn't really have that much competition to be
fair i want to thank all the original devs that worked in
the last of us part two all my homies back i will say there
was not a lot of competition for them thanks to all the
support we got from playstation productions sony picture
yeah like two three of those three of the people here the
shows that were in there show slash movies was really really
bad from what i've heard i heard double make was really bad
and um um what was the last one at the bottom until john was
really bad and then like sonic wasn't even nominated but the
sonic movie was like the best one apparently and we're super
proud of what they've done thank you to the game awards
thank you very much i can't believe minecraft didn't win um
excuse me the last of us what about chicken jockey oh what
the last of us Nothing.
The Game Awards main event.
My car movie gave us mine and craft and chicken jockey and
blint and steel.
They gave us, the last of us gave us zero memes.
I am Steve and Jack Black.
It gave us Jack Black.
The announcement of the next Tomb Raider, which is just.
minutes away and that's just one of the look at that the
memes were endless there are a lot of other ones that are so
secret all i get to see are a long list of code names i'm
being completely serious anyway thank you for going on this
journey with me and congratulations again to all the yeah i
can't believe the minecraft movie made jack black guys the
2025 game awards starts now
All right, Sound Guy, I hope...
Is this volume okay now?
All right.
First real trailer.
I can't...
Yeah, I can't believe they finally announced Silk Song that
now we don't...
What do we have now?
What do we have to look forward to?
Not that they've announced Silk Song.
Oh, yeah, Blood Point.
Yeah, but then you guys are actually coping, though.
Sok song at least it felt a little real
Sok song actually felt real It was like it was like you know
it definitely could it could happen but the others you're
The others are just cool
Yeah, okay a bit more Is this clear Where's the flute guy?
guitar man.
What the fuck?
He said, Fluka, we got guitar, man.
I assume it's...
I assume they open with Claire.
Like I said, they're okay with Claire, but I know what
everyone says is really good.
I just knew it's just not my type of game genre.
And I know if I play it, people are gonna get really mad at
me.
I know what my game... Like, I know what games work with me
the best.
I will say None of them will ever top Alan Wake Alan Wake
too That was peak for me That was the most fever dream
Because I didn't play 2 yet So I was like What the fuck is
going?
We're not going back to...
I am not replaying Alan Wake 2, guys.
There's no way to salvage the save file either.
Oh my god, bro.
He's fucking ripping it.
You go, buddy.
Guys, I'm not replaying from the beginning, guys.
I'm not doing it going back from the beginning.
He's shredding it.
You know what?
Do you remember how fucking scary it is?
I do remember.
I remember being fucking scared.
Perfection is not attainable or affordable.
Excellent.
What the... Oh, okay.
It's part of the trailer.
I was like, are they giving me, like, quotes now?
Like, inspirational quotes?
I was like, wondering where this quote came from.
Sometimes we paint the bars of our own.
Are these Jeff quotes?
He chose a hard girl for yourself.
I guess these are all the games that came out in 2025.
Also, Donkey Kong looks so like out of place here.
What the fuck?
Also, here's a monkey.
Everything is so serious.
By the way, he's a gorilla.
Oh, shit.
Oh, sash cap.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
We can work with it.
Okay, this is bad.
I laughed a little too hard.
This is me.
Thank you for the five gifts.
It sucks.
What the fuck is Lego doing here?
You know me, headmistress.
I know enough to get in the trouble.
Is this what my tomorrow will be?
That's your name.
Welcome to the Game Awards 2025.
Yeah!
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Good.
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Good evening, everyone.
Welcome to the game awards a night to celebrate the best and
discover what's next in video games Tonight we are connected
through our love of games thousands of us here at peacock
theater and millions more watching around the world Yeah,
that's me.
Oh my god, there's 893,000 people watching on Twitch alone I
do have co-stream with this.
Thank you to Elise de Port-Persier.
Oh, whatever doesn't it's okay oh my god they're so french
and of course that is the most nominated yeah there's 900
there's 900k people watching members of the team from
sandfall interactive are here on twitch alone identify them
based on their uh attire tonight welcome guys it's great to
have you here you know every year this show reminds us why
video games matter they are worlds we share stories we build
and experiences that challenge, inspire, and connect us like
nothing else, especially when life gets hard.
I don't usually open up about personal things on stage, but
2025 tested me in ways I didn't expect.
Me too, bro.
Me too.
I lost my tooth.
Oh, that's pretty bad, actually.
That's worse than me.
Oh, that's all right.
That's a lot worse.
I'm so sorry, bro.
I can't compare.
My mom's here tonight and we've left an empty seat beside
her in his own reason i didn't know i didn't know but in the
middle i didn't know he quit through all that this show and
all of you became the source of strength for me i think
about this night this moment and this community and it gave
me something to look forward to it reminded me how important
it is to celebrate games games have this incredible ability
to hold us when we're hurting to lift us up when we feel
small to give us somewhere to go when the real world feels
unsteady.
I know I'm not alone in knowing that.
All of you watching tonight, you've felt that power too.
And that's why we're all connected in this moment.
Yeah!
Gamers, you nut!
Gamers Rise Up!
I had an Overwatch name called Gamers Rise Up.
And then Blizzard made me change my name because they said
it's like a hate speech.
a record-setting three independent titles up for Game of the
Year.
This just gave me a free name change because they were like,
this is a hate speech.
I have to change my name.
We are going to have some fun, of course, too, with a whole
slate of brand new game announcements that will hopefully
get you excited about the limitless future ahead.
So let's get going.
To present our first award, a father and son.
Gamers of Press.
He is one of the finest performers working today.
From Isaac and the last of us to Chase.
dispatch and his son brings young chase to life in dispatch
as well please welcome to the game awards jeffrey and elijah
wright yeah gamers sit down
advice thank you with tier one sub thank you thank you wow
uh this is incredible uh i'm i'm so excited to be here
tonight in the company of uh so many incredible artists and
gaming fans.
Woo!
Gamers, gamers, gamers!
New frontiers of storytelling.
I'm going to look up how to do this.
But the reason I'm here really is standing next to me.
My son Elijah.
It was Elijah who brought me into the world of modern games
emphatically encouraging me to join the cast of the last of
us part two.
And now he's joined me in.
voicing chase and track star in dispatch yeah it's chase and
chase out there i think yeah cool all right let's see
co-streaming guidelines if it weren't for elijah guidelines
for co-streaming how to begin co-streaming right keep up i
can't believe i'm standing on the stage today as an artist
i'm thrilled enable co-stream button under the co-stream
section in the edit info.
I mean, I guess it's nice that you're here too, Dad.
Thank you.
Thank you, Elijah.
Gotcha, I got you.
The next award honors games that are high octane, high
action, and combat heavy.
Here are the nominees for the best action game.
I give up.
Oh, he said the thing.
Best action game.
Learning to cook.
Oh, best action game?
I've given up.
I don't know.
It's too much work.
I tried.
I tried to figure it out.
And...
That is Hades, right?
It has to be Hades.
Yeah.
Battlefield 6 shooters rise up.
Bro, they just made Battlefield 6 free to play.
I don't think Battlefield 6 is winning anything.
I'm sorry, guys.
thank you um the seven of us who worked on our first action
game bastion all still work together at super giant games um
we've been joined by so many people who helped make hades 2
and the original hades what it is on behalf yeah it's gonna
be free to play who worked on the game we just want to
express no zombies is gonna be free to play too who make
such incredible work in this industry and inspire us and we
want to say thank you to our players who literally help make
this game what it is through its early access.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Congratulations, Amir, Greg, and the whole Super Giant team.
That's amazing.
Oh, extreme.
All right.
Now we move into one of my favorite, and yes, sometimes very
dangerous parts of the evening.
Oh, extreme.
From the moment where we look ahead at what's coming next
from some of the world's most talented game creators.
There's speculation online about what may or may not appear
on that screen tonight.
And as always, my only advice is enjoy the journey.
Maybe you'll witness the birth of a brand new universe or
the long-awaited return of a legend.
That's the magic of this show.
Anything can happen.
So let's get started.
It's time for our very first world premiere, something truly
special that we're honored to debut here at the Game Awards.
Finally a first world premiere Use the people what they want
Is this Blood Boy 2?
It's space I should have made a bingo Be like extraction
shooter My bingo card would be extraction shooter Space
zombies Post-apocalyptic Ha ha ha
Now, Battle Royale is old.
Battle Royale is now retro.
It's now extraction shooters, baby.
Is it Star Wars?
Yeah, I was gonna say, this looks like Star Wars.
It feels like Star Wars.
Because she's wearing a robe.
Or like a cape robe thing.
Yeah, I fucking knew it.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
The Old Republic.
The
Old Republic.
Star Wars Fate of the Old Republic is a brand new single
player action role playing game set in the Old Republic era,
of course, and directed by Casey Hudson, who's joining us
here tonight.
Casey was, of course, the director on Star Wars Knights of
the Old Republic.
Oh!
That's a good trailer to start it off.
It's always the first game trailer, first world premiere,
and the last world premiere.
That's the most hype.
We have a very special guest I'd like to bring out.
That's a good trailer.
Yay, Miss B!
Oh my god, in front of Kermit.
Oh my god, you have a wife and you have a husband.
ever turn down an invitation from you oh which
by the way was certainly not a boar approved by disney
oh the best part is that the script was approved by disney
that's the only one you need to do something later you have
a really special moment later in the show you're gonna be
doing it and t are my game awards boo jeffy boo that's crazy
i can't wait miss piggy we'll see you later so excited yes
she just came out to be like yeah i'm having a secret affair
with jeff what's not so secret anymore
here for survival training of course you are pathetic now
we've compiled some valuable training material wait isn't
that guy a streamer against the hungry undead um we can just
run around those right that guy's a streamer right silence
both of you out there yeah more than your foolish instincts
yeah maximilian i was like what the fuck Well, I do love a
good fight.
But do you like winning them?
You know, you got paid a lot for a million dollar trailer?
Yeah!
Only Moushia!
I'd like to talk more about the samurai and demons.
Well, this is survival training.
Not survival talking.
And lucky for all you helpless half-wits.
Yeah, this is Xbox Pass?
On some top-notch materials.
There's no...
Oh, Capcom.
Oh, a cell.
Oh.
It's Red Sek.
It's a lot of fun.
Dad, it's free.
Free Red Seks?
Do you think anyone here said sex?
He said sex.
You said free.
Oh.
The Redacted Sector.
Really?
Yeah.
Is that the name it is?
We gotta jump.
Am I supposed to have a big gun?
No.
You're gonna find big guns down there and we might even get
a tank noob.
Oh, a tank.
We're not getting a tank if we don't jump.
Oh, we need to jump.
Yes.
Go, go, go.
Go!
It's Red Seks.
Oh I think the worst part is they paid a million dollars for
that.
I think I think that's oh
If I is it was it worth it?
Did you get the joke guys?
He said sex instead of sex guys
No, they spent all the budget on the on getting a slot
Getting an ad slot.
And there's like, okay, we have like $500 left.
We can't hurt us if they can't catch us.
We gotta get out of here.
Right now.
The zombie is redundant.
I prefer
you.
This is toxic.
Carpenters.
Now it's time to put an end to gaming's most controversial
mystery.
Oh?
What?
Oh, is this about the statue?
Oh, yeah, the statue.
The fucking random statue in the field.
The Amish right here.
That's not the Amish.
Oh, hey, too.
They're going to be flying.
Oh, goodbye, son.
You're going to hell.
I guess you, too.
You committed some sin.
You guys held hands before marriage.
That's bad in the old times.
The rapture.
I don't think...
I think it's the opposite of the rapture.
What the fuck?
Oh, seizure warning.
I did not like that.
Is this God of War?
Nah, this does not look Elden Ring-ish.
I don't know.
Is it witchy?
Do you think it's witchy?
That pre-rendered footage.
Yeah, I was gonna say this too happy to be Elden Ring.
Definitely something fantasy.
There's like elves and shit.
And dwarves.
This is...
Guys, this is Sims.
It could be Fable.
New IP?
The question is whether or not it's a new IP.
Divinity 3?
I don't know what Divinity 3...
Divinity series is.
I've heard of the name, but I don't really remember what
game it is.
of game it is what the fuck did this guy do it's not he's
not a witch because he's not a he's not a woman could burn
it tax evasion mad
witch this is what happens when you evade taxes guys oh what
the fuck Oh, that's evil blood.
Oh, oh, oh, hey, there's sex over there.
You know sex, not sex.
Oh, oh.
Okay, guys, maybe burning him alive was not a good idea.
Yeah, they might have.
have fucked up with burning them alive.
Larian?
Oh, there's a statue.
Divinity.
Oh, Divinity 3.
Oh, it's Baldur's Gate 3 devs.
So is it a new IP then?
Oh, it's Divinity.
Yeah.
I have no idea what this game is about, though.
What a that statue or monument that has fascinated the
internet now has a name the hellstone and yes larian winners
of game of the year in 2023 for bouldersgate 3 are hard at
work on their next role-playing game a continuation of the
divinity saga divinity is their biggest game ever is
divinity yeah i'm gonna say it's divinity like bouldersgate
3 promising more breadth and depth than ever before and we
cannot wait to tell you more in the future to present our
next award two previous winners of best performance here at
the Game Awards, Maggie Robertson and Neil Nubon.
I would love to do predictions, but it just goes by so fast,
and I don't know the order of the nomination stuff.
I don't know what the order is.
It's just so fucking fast, too.
For the record, Neil said that he was wearing the dress this
year, so...
i can do game of the year prediction we'll just go straight
to game of the year that's at the end slash prediction they
just go too fast for me to do it they say acting is the art
of pretending all right start prediction what are the game
of the year guys what's the list you're someone else and
then winning awards for lying uh listen i've actually based
my entire career on this we really need to have a you know
it's called comedy lock in e33 versus what donkey guys we
need to take e33 or donkey god all right who's the second
most likely donkey god okay i'll do silk song all right e33
or silk song and teenage girls forced to survive
extraordinary psychological and physical terror.
The point is acting is serious business and we are serious
actors here to talk about acting seriously.
Uh, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Thank you for the gift of tier one gift of tier one sub.
Best performance.
I didn't make the rules between you two.
Ben Star.
We'll break the cycle.
Charlie Cox.
Apparently the Charlie Cox actor wondered it to be like his
body double to win it.
Or like the motion capture actor.
It's all clear.
It's crazy.
It's like Charlie or Ben, right?
I like how they gave Troy Baker a freebie.
And the game award goes to...
Is that Ben or Charlie?
Jennifer England!
Oh shit!
Jennifer?
She didn't expect that.
Oh.
Whoa, that's a surprise.
I didn't even know what she played.
I just knew about Ben or Charlie.
Should I go all in for E33?
Oh, she played like the girl.
Oh, yeah, the Potentail Girl.
I don't even know about it because I saw art of it from
Hades.
Because I was like, who's the girl in the Hades art?
Or in the Game of the Year artwork.
This takes a village.
And oh my god, I love my passionate, yeah, Mel.
Mel?
I don't really know how to pronounce it.
Hooray wearing village.
Every single one of you, Guillaume Jen special shout out to
Charlotte and Adeline and of course my wonderful Ben who has
been my ride or die throughout all of this my big brother
that's cute thank you thank you to my beautiful that you
didn't win to every neurodivergent person watching yeah
thank you for the twitch prize thank you and at home to all
of you that feel like life is stuck on hard mode this one is
for you and thank you so much to the games community and
industry for giving us so many of us a home for those who
come last three game of the year had her in it geez i feel
like that's like a prophecy if she chooses your game to be
voice acted in you're like you have a chance she's like the
lucky charm i am neurodivergent okay i think like a lot of
us like we're all neurodivergent guys we're all
neurodivergent from bad robot games please welcome jj abrams
and the creator of left for dead mike booth
i don't think this actually i don't think you're actually no
one's actually fully normal life's fucking hard guys life's
hard we've been so oh shit jj abrams to get to work with
some incredible artists to tell stories on stage, TV, and
film.
And it's been an absolute thrill and honor to have spent the
last few years working with a brilliant Mike Booth on an
original universe that brings our passion for great
storytelling to the PlayStation and PC.
Thank you, JJ.
At our Bad Robot Game Studio, working with our friends at
PlayStation, we've been creating a new kind of co-op game
that builds upon what I learned making Left 4 Dead.
The result is something entirely different.
An unpredictable, challenging combat sandbox where you
succeed through cooperation and improvisation.
And now I am excited to share a glimpse into what we've been
working on.
In fact, we're also inviting all of you to sign up for early
playtesting and check it out for yourselves.
But first, welcome to For Loop.
Welcome back, team.
Now, I need you to brace yourselves.
Earth was invaded.
Lost in less than a minute.
All of this was our fault.
We're the only ones left who can fix it.
And you must use our machine.
I swear to God, if this is an extraction shooter, JJ, I
swear to God.
I know what you're thinking.
This bloke's gone insane.
plan sounds impossible and we're probably going to die i
swear to god jj going to die it's all part of my new plan
every time you fail i will use our machine to bring you back
oh it's like that robert patterson movie what is it called
it's literally the same plot test strategies learn from your
failures Mickey yeah Mickey 17 this feels very extraction
shooter JJ JJ why are you making another extraction shooter
play for loop for loop up next we have new game announcement
from some of the developers who helped put the last of us
and uncharted into our hands this new small independent
studio is charting its own course focused on crafting
uniquely styled artful games that are pushing the evolution
of companion characters enjoy oh is it like pokemon
this is pokemon
where are my companion characters this is just a forest
Hello, this is a human, not a companion monster.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there's my Pokemans.
But don't use a ball device to capture.
You might get sued.
It's fucking crazy that got trademarked.
Yeah, now they lost it.
They lost the pattern because the judge was like, wait, this
is fucking crazy.
You can't pattern this.
Wait a minute.
Oh, this is like...
What game am I thinking of?
The guys who did Shadow Colossus, the one with the bird
monster thing?
Or she does have chicken feet.
Kyle, thank you for the 500 biddies.
Thank you.
The last guardian.
Yeah.
the last guardian if i if it loses my family goes hungry i
went all in on e3d
coven of the chicken feet oh she's mama what's her name the
the russian witch is that her
oh baba yaga yeah
Is that Baba Yaga?
Rats!
There's so many rats.
Oh my god, they're humping the electronics.
Oh, from Soma.
That's from the creators of Soma.
Oh, that's some creepy faces.
What is existence?
Really?
Rats.
We are the rats.
Your father thought it was name of the drama game something
something chicken feet hope another chicken feet
Oh, oh, oh, I don't like that You want to understand to know
we got three ohs.
Oh, wow four ohs for me Oh, the walls around you Oh, god Oh
Yeah, it is it.
Yeah, definitely from the soma does
Jeez.
What's it called?
Antos?
Ant-T-O-S.
I assume Antos.
Whoa, thank you for your one-stop.
Thank you.
Antos from Fracture Games, a sci-fi mystery and spiritual
successor to Soma, set on a repurposed hotel on the moon,
and yes, the unmistakable Stellan Skarsgarde will start in
the game.
What is Stellan Skarsgarde?
It's time to reveal a new forceful void hunter in Hoyo
versus...
Pennywise?
ARPG.
That's the Pennywise out there.
Meet Ye Shuanguan, the first ever dual form agent.
Yeah.
Actually, that game does look very interesting, though.
Never played Soma.
But I've heard everyone told me like Soma's really
interesting.
Like a really interesting game.
Is this Genshin?
Oh, ZZ's.
Oh, it's Zenless.
Close enough.
Oh, she cute.
In like a killer way.
I like her design.
It's like...
There's just something about like a tiny guy wielding a big
ass sword.
Bro, everybody knows how to co-stream the game rewards
except me.
The saddest, everyone's like, co-streaming the game rewards.
And I'm just like, how the fuck do you do that?
Whatever.
Aw, checkies.
Look, more is critical than it is in co-streaming.
streaming it.
I'm just as cool as him.
That game was so scary when I did like a playtest with Duby.
It's like...
I don't know.
Maybe you'll get a gun later, but it felt like she
definitely could not hold a gun.
I hope they don't touch Timo.
Or Timo?
Timo?
Yeah, Timo.
Because I know how tilting he is, apparently.
What Timo?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, shit.
Oh, she's in.
The girlfriend's in.
For a limited time only, Prime members can go to amazon.com
slash the game awards to save up to $20 You get to save up
to 25% off select nominees!
Wait, who the fuck buys physical?
Wait, no.
From the award-winning games, Journey and Sky.
I just realized it's like you can buy physical games.
That game company's CEO and creative director, Genova
Channel.
I can't even put that on my PC.
I do.
But PCs don't even have the CD ports anymore.
Just give you a fucking code.
And tonight's game for impact nominees.
That's the worst part.
You buy physical copy and like the inside is just a fucking
code.
That's what like PC like that's what physical copies for PC
games are now.
How interactive art bring us closer together.
We get nothing but a goddamn paper with a code on it.
It's just an empty box.
It's literally a fake physical.
I've never had any friends like you.
We forgot for a reason.
It's not safe out there, Hazel.
If I was the one missing, she wouldn't stop looking.
Graham, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Yeah, you guys have an Amazon Prime.
You can subscribe to your favorite streamer for free.
I.e.
Jeff, I guess.
Because the chat is all Twitch Prime and Jeff's channel.
Guys, you can subscribe to your favorite streamer, Jeff,
once a year.
Treen, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
No, every month, but Jeff only streams once a year.
Imagine someone, like, every month that there's no Game of
the Year show, they still fucking subscribe to Twitch Prime
him.
I would like to share this award with all of you and of
course to our incredible team back home and every single
players who's been part of this journey.
Aw, that's sweet.
From the start, we listen to...
You can subscribe to your favorite streamer for free every
month, which is nice.
To build a world that would feel as warm and as rich as the
sun.
one, guys.
That's too busy showing Twitch Prime.
Sorry.
I'm too busy helping Jeff show Twitch Prime.
South of Midnight?
Oh.
We're incredibly excited to launch what was the category for
this?
South of Midnight on PlayStation 5.
Lucifer Khan.
Thank you so much.
Impact?
Yay.
Oh, they're also French.
Oh my god, this is actually going to be a French.
French sweep.
Teams with impact.
Tonight, one of the most iconic survival horror franchises
returns to the Game Award stage.
There's an EVA?
For nearly three decades, Resident Evil has defined what it
means to face the unknown.
I knew it!
To survive against impossible odds.
This next installment, Resident Evil Requiem is a nominee
for most anticipated game.
And tonight, we're excited to dive deeper.
mess up for me to say i hope it's um i hope i hope it
doesn't like it's not what was it i hope it's not like
people don't go in with too much high expectations like they
did with silent hill
i hope this exceeds expectations or live up to it because i
heard i didn't play silent hill but i heard people were like
yeah um people were like i wish we i lowered my expectations
to silent Oh yeah, apparently Leon's back and he's like 50
now or some shit.
Here we finally are.
Who are you?
You're the one that I've been searching for.
Someone help Leon retire.
He's tired, man.
He's so fucking tired.
He's like, please, I don't want to go back to Raccoon City.
No, that's not Leon.
Leon, don't worry.
He's still handsome.
He's like a delf now.
It might be unrelated, but he disappeared near where the
fifth body was found.
Oh, shit.
That's me.
My cameo.
Elpis can finally be...
Me and my tooth.
I guess teeth.
The team has settled on a person of...
interest someone with ties to umbrella victor gideon who's
victor
victor purchased a building after umbrella went under i'll
send you the address
do you guys actually need the volume to be high Welcome.
Dr. Gideon has been expecting you.
Oh, she looks normal at least.
Oh, there's Leon!
There he is!
You there, Leon?
God, he's so fucking tired.
He's so done.
Like, stop bringing me back.
Bro, he...
Bro.
Oh, he's so fucking tired.
Don't do anything stupid.
Me?
Never.
Oh no, he's getting hotter!
Why is he still hot?
Oh, thank God.
We can actually play...
Oh my God!
Thank God!
Okay.
I'm just happy we can actually play with a play as I'm so
happy we can play as the uh because when I played as the
other girl she was like she oh my god she was like the
stealth version historian requiem will intertwine the fate
of two playable characters he's so cool guys through a
unique survival he's still so flexible even in his 50s
explosive action to the game uh it's gonna be exciting thank
god all right yeah because Claire was like the uh it was
like in set you were seven created outside the traditional
big publisher system so we felt it was important to
spotlight those visionary projects tonight right alongside
the big franchises this next game is a good example it comes
from a legendary name in the independent scene someone I
first met back in 2007 it's a project that has been ten
years in the making
charm that goblin it's too far i'll swap him out what the
fuck east the mirror oils will the mirrors repair my soul
will i pass the test oh it's a puzzle game endless caverns
beams of light nobody else could get this old what's going
on it's a puzzle game skipping stones to lonely homes close
to the treasure just a few more minutes if you don't
He sounds so happy with the idea that they might die.
He's like, ha ha, we might die, guys.
Ha ha.
That's the
sound guy.
Did it up the volume a little bit more?
Let me know if it is too loud or not.
I had never imagined such a device that could fuse
realities.
Whoa.
Okay, brain hurt time.
It weaves the very laws of nature into a composite hole.
result surprises me constantly but who yeah brain hurt now
and what do they
want yeah no i'm too dumb for the puzzle i i professor laden
is my most favorite game of all time like game series
adventure with over 1400 puzzles but like but that's
different i think professor laden is like a different type
of puzzle game than this traveling 40 000 years into the
future for a brand new look at exodus why not in here they
give the two one something thank you from wizards of the
coast and archetype entertainment for decades wizards has
built worlds where players define their own legacies exodus
carries that tradition into the stars it's time to step
forward didn't the guy that originally made the puzzles for
professor laden died i remember maybe i'm making that up i
may be spreading fake news but i remember reading something
about like how like someone passed away in the professor
laden team celestials are the enemy of you How did he die?
Old age, because he's really old.
Like, I hope I'm spreading fake news.
I just remembered, like, the guy who fucking made majority
of the puzzles for Professor Layden is a very, very old man.
He's sure he didn't die.
I was like, how did he die?
I don't fuck know.
When you get too old, then it has to stop one day.
One day, it eventually stops.
It never stops, Toki.
The crime never stops.
Yeah, this does look like Mass Effect.
What about the hot aliens?
What's the point?
Why is my crew fully human?
Are we, like, fucking discriminating?
Like...
Zeno, skull.
This is a human-only crew.
Bro, I could have a fucking bear in my crew and said I'm
beating it up.
No aliens on my shit.
how much are you willing to sacrifice to save your world I
mean the game really looks badass no pressure there the only
downside is that I can't kiss a hot alien on my crew Exodus
early 2027 oh my god that's far Exodus is coming in early
2027 and i'm very excited to play it but that's not all from
wizards of the coast tonight oh wizards from the coast oh
yeah because it was like dungeons and dragons they're like
from the creators of dungeons and dragons
wizard of the coast making video games surprising i'm not
i'm not because it's like it's like the next i feel like
that's the next step a new wizards of the coast studio where
i play the main character that's unlike anything i've done
before oh just owners not creators ah of what we've been
working on let's take a look all of this magic this pact we
have forged what's this what is the cost
oh she turned gawth
twirl in a trailer what's What does that mean?
Oh, it's a band.
Oh!
I don't.
I'm bad with music.
Warlock, Dungeons &...
Oh.
Gameplay Revere.
Warlock.
On Warlock coming in summer 2026.
Oh, they're making two games.
I mean, Warlock is coming up.
Coming up like Performance by Evanescence who are also
releasing a new version of their hit song Afterlife.
Yeah, I was gonna say Avalescence.
What?
From labyrinth with Sonic the Hedgehog and Bill Murray.
Not that Bill Murray, a different one with Cyberpunk Edge
Runners.
Here is your first lesson.
Love, mom.
I did not expect that.
It's like, it's Sade!
Unfortunately that they made music for your devil make cry
to show.
It's very unfortunate.
Very unfortunate because I think like only maybe like a
thousand people listened to that song.
Never saw the new devil make cry on me.
Yeah, me too.
warned me that it was really bad.
I didn't bother.
Oh hey, E33.
They gave him the 100 biddies, they could thank him!
Their brands were still on fire and their hoods were made of
steel.
Their horns were black and shiny and their hot breath he
could feel.
No, it's just the Xbox Game Pass.
You guys might have missed it, but they're advertising the
Game Pass right now.
I hear all the games in the Xbox Game Pass.
Yeah, unfortunately, this is an in-show.
I mean, the entire thing is an ad.
Oh, this is a cabin game, isn't it?
Yeah,
this entire show is not technically.
I told you guys, this is Super Bowl of ads.
This is the gamer Super Bowl.
He's here.
It's him.
It's Gabrielle.
What?
What is this?
Is this a show or a game?
I feel like this has to be a show, right?
Oh,
it's a game.
The Screamer tournament is about to be announced.
Held by a Mr. A.
Consider this.
Your personal invitation.
Burn alive, you piece of shit.
It's like, um...
It's like...
What is it?
It's like this patchy.
Where like...
Maybe like...
A like visual novel with the game.
Or like cutscenes with the game.
Screamer.
Welcome back to the Game Awards, and now it's time for a
game announcement for a studio...
I'm racing in my anime.
The limits of storytelling.
Never die!
They captivate us with worlds that bend reality and stories
that blur the line between ordinary and the impossible.
They're one of the most distinct voices in our industry, and
whenever they show up, you know you're about to see
something unlike anything else.
What's this?
is this
music what the fuck kojima i'm sorry this is how it's like
kojamba
is he gonna do it again this
looks very kojamba-ish guys that
Or control.
I was going to say.
It looks like control too.
Oh, is that the control lady?
I saw it.
It looked like the style from the devs behind.
What are you doing, they made?
Something is coming.
He's in the cube.
Oh.
Oh, God.
That's so true.
Triffy.
Yeah, Max Payne.
Max Payne and Alan Wake.
Oh, I don't...
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, seizure warning.
Yeah, that's trippy.
I thought he was like, bar, game pass now.
It's like the hypnoprag.
Oh shit, Inception!
Wait, this is so Inception-like.
Oh god.
This has to be in the control universe, right?
Because it's like the SCP shit.
Oh
Hey, he got a bigger cube.
It's now a rectangle
Yay Rise and shine
Oh Shit
What the fuck Oh my
god What the fuck is going on outside?
That's a big ass hammer.
Oh shit.
That's so fucking trippy.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
That is so fucking trippy.
Yeah, there's, yeah.
Oh yeah, it does look Devil May Cry-ish with the gameplay.
The fights look so fucking trippy too.
Dude, he was like upside down at one point.
That is a good one.
Control Resonant is coming in 2026 from the Masters at
Remedy Entertainment in Finland whose last game, Alan Wake,
won multiple awards here at the Game Awards in 2023,
including Best Game Direction.
It is always exciting to have past TGA winners return to our
show to showcase their upcoming projects.
I wanted to get a discount.
tonight we'll have a performance from avanescence plus
awards including best score and music best narrative best
game direction and game of the year like if you win if
you're nominated for something or you win something you just
have to show your trailer there are more new game
announcements ahead it's like here's a coupon code if you
want to show something we're going to use a coupon code if
you want to advertise your game we've got a brand new
all the way from Tokyo, Japan and a legendary game
developer.
He's working on an ambitious new project and we are honored
he chose TGA Kojamba?
That's a place to share the first details and in-engine
footage with the world.
What?
Is this Yakuza?
Yeah, it looks like Yakuza.
What?
Did you just see it?
Bro, did you just see it?
What did they do?
Jinjizo, yeah?
Oh, as Yaaku said, oh, did you guys see it?
He's like, yeah!
So when the audience was like, yeah!
Oh!
Hey, Daiki, when'd you make it back?
Excuse me, sir!
Shut your mouth!
Alright, talk soon.
I mean it's a spin it could be just a new IP but in a yakuza
like similar to yakuza
this looks less ha ha funny yakuza and more like it gets
real this shit's real now
yeah this looks like serious yakuza
Yakuza if it was real Yeah, yeah, that's basically it If
Yakuza was real
Gang of Dragon What a fucking title Thank you for that
announcement Alright, next up is something very cool and
very unexpected Get your quarters ready stick yakuza time is
coming to the big screen we're taking it back to the 90s
when the ultimate rivalries were settled in the arcade not
settled at all special sneak peek of street fighter let's
take a look if yakuza was here again that's crazy gang of
dragon with a wild oh it's a street fighter movie
Wait, what's the that?
Isn't that Key from Key and Peel?
That guy looks like Ludwig.
Yeah, I was gonna say Ludwig.
Yeah, dude, I think I saw Eric Andre.
Bro, I think I saw him too.
Well, the fiercest fighters have gathered to stake their
claim.
Time to meet some of the warriors stepping into the ring.
Eric Andre.
Now, where is Zambi?
Excuse me.
You can't have a street fighter without his loyal fans.
Oh my god, Cody Rhodes.
That's crazy.
Where the fuck is my Eric Andre?
Woo!
Oh my god, he does look like him.
My loyal fans!
Oh my god, Jay!
Jason Mamoa as a Blanca!
What?
They got Mr. Mamoa?
What the fuck is he blocked?
Oh my god.
Still cheaper than the cast of Avengers.
That's the craziest part.
Still cheaper than getting the cast of Avengers.
Now I know our movie comes out like a year from now, but
there was no Bro, Jason is having a sad quest right now.
He got announced to be like, what's his name?
Lobo?
Is it Lobo?
From DC?
On camera.
I kind of miss that, guys.
We miss it too.
Yeah, Lobo.
Sorry, Lobo.
Yeah, he got announced as Lobo yesterday or today.
And now he got announced as Licky Blanca.
He didn't hire me to play Blanca.
True story, words matter.
I think Jason Mamoa took up 70% of it.
of the casting budget there's no fucking way where the fuck
is eric andre i what is eric andre
the games in this category are the ones that never quit
delivering all year long they keep us looking forward yeah
no he is a perfect lobo i will say he is a perfect lobo but
like him as blanca was like surprising we need more
presenters this ain't enough you know what i'm saying i'm
saying geese is like i don't know why i'm here guys it's so
important that we appreciate you all here for being great
patrons oh he actually looks like if you play the game make
some noise and you're like just chilling you should be in
this goddamn underwear is not possible without you guys we
are so grateful and we're not the only game that appreciates
your how dare you cloven so there's another game out there
they also flew from around the world to be here because they
appreciate you.
So give it up for the whole cast of Mortal Kombat 2.
I'm just kidding.
They didn't come.
They don't care about you.
I'm not feeling immersed right now.
Damn.
Guys, someone take his mic away, guys.
He's joking.
Someone take his mic away.
For best ongoing game.
Woo!
Best ongoing game.
I'll protect my people's happiness to the last.
It cuts out my gap.
I can't believe it.
Eric Andre didn't come to the game.
He's too good for the game awards.
Guys, I'm so sad.
Oh, hey, my vavas.
We couldn't have burst keep my vavas.
I can't believe Nomad's guy is going so strong.
You know, my...
I saw a clip like...
a couple of days ago.
Oh, the mic's not coming out of the floor.
I thought I was coming out of the floor.
And the game award goes to No Man's Sky.
Oh, shit!
That's crazy.
I did not expect that.
Yeah, that's the redemption arc right there.
Okay, so the last time, the last I saw a clip of No Man's
Sky, but apparently some dude found the planet in No Man's
Sky that randomly generated.
We're all the month where all the citizens were just penises
did you guys see that clip and the guy was riding a dick
it's just fancy yeah someone found a randomly generated
world where it was just peepies everywhere he was like
riding like a horse the fact that it was randomly generated
dude that's like I'm slightly jet lagged myself.
Oh, let me see if I can find this clip.
I'm just going to be very sorry he isn't here.
I'm also slightly sorry he's not here because this is way
more than our friend.
I guess I was like, look at this.
But, you know, just that our tiny, massive, impossible space
game still means something to so many people that we get to
keep on making a game that we love.
That is a real privilege.
You know, that we are able to be here on a stage surrounded
by so many incredible games.
Like, that is really special.
I should have bookmarked it, guys.
It's like a sharer to the class.
Thank you so much.
All right, let me...
I'll find it.
Don't worry.
Now I am committed.
No man's Skype.
EGIS.
Oh, there you go.
There.
This was a randomly generated world.
I think that's the craziest part.
No Man's Sky.
And how about the Street Fighter cast?
That was absolutely wild.
Alright.
There's lots more game awards ahead, including a very
special announcement.
Oh, Batman!
Well, we'll pick it up, I guess.
They got released before Netflix buys the company.
Oh, it's Lego Batman.
All the way from Gotham City.
Lego Gotham.
How you doing, buddy?
It's great to see you tonight.
You having a good time?
Commissioner Keeley.
Sorry I couldn't make it in person.
I've been trying to decide what bats are doing.
Yeah, that's not Will Arnett.
Abs or no abs.
Anyway, great show so far.
But it's about to get even better.
Because it's time for a new look at my upcoming game.
Lego Batman.
Legacy of the Dark Knight.
Batman out.
Will Arnett was too expensive.
guys you gotta release this before netflix buys everything
that's crazy that paramount came it oh my god wait that's
the wait i like how the joker is the oh shit it's the dark
night joke it's heath ledger joker yeah like the joker is
heath ledger
let's get to work
Oh, shit.
That's classic Catwoman, too.
This town deserves a better class of criminal.
Good evening, Gotham.
Join us in a celebration of absolute chaos.
Let's get to the root of the problem.
We don't do that.
This is a serious game, Robin.
Oh shit, yeah, these are all the movie Batman.
That was Arnold.
That was Arnold Iceman.
Not Iceman, sorry.
Lego Batman Legacy of the Dark Knight launches on May 29th,
2026.
Everyone starts with Mad now.
of teams across the freeze sorry arnold freeze ah yes ice
man from pc comics oh is it gonna be e33 again on the beach
ghost of yote and silent hill f this year the game award
goes to battlefield six congratulations look i was saying i
said fat man so much creator of the year.
Kedrel, Kai Sanat, Moist Critical, Sakuro, Miko, and the
Merge Peanut.
And the Game Award goes to Moist Critical.
Oh!
Here are the nominees for Best on How You Reacted.
He's actually watching the stream right now.
Fatal Fury City of the Wolves Mortal Kombat Legacy
Collection.
I'm gonna check it now.
The Game Award goes to to Fatal Fury, City of the Warriors.
All right.
Here are the nominees for the new fighting game, 2XKO.
Okay.
Marvel Wolverine, Resident Evil Retrium and the Witcher 4.
The game award goes to Grand Theft Auto 6.
Looking around for more of the game awards.
Some of tonight's biggest surprises are still ahead.
And of course later, the Game Awards Orchestra and Lauren
Bell pay tribute to our game of the year nominees.
He hasn't said anything after.
All he said was, yup.
Wait, did he say anything?
Oh,
he says- Thanks, chat.
Pay tribute to our game of the year nominees.
channel is stopped
yep That crazy
He's so humble yet He's so humble Yep
He's so cool.
I just, I don't know.
I don't know.
I felt like it made me.
I guess I expected too much, guys.
How can I be humble like him, guys?
An ad for rust?
Oh, yeah.
I'm surprised.
An ad for rust.
That's crazy.
Yeah, in 2025.
Is this Rust Mobile?
Oh, is this for Mobile?
Oh, shit, it is.
Ha ha, that's right.
Jesus Christ.
Is this gonna burn my phone?
I wonder what the real one feels like.
Bro, is that gonna burn my fucking phone?
Felicia Day.
Oh, Felicia Day.
I've seen her in so long.
But she was like the nerd actress for everyone.
It was like every nerd's like celebrity crush back in the
day.
The TGA Game Changer Award.
An award that recognizes an individual or organization that
has demonstrated positive social progress in the gaming
industry.
She was like, she used to be everywhere.
No, she was for like all the everyone that was like.
Oh shit, the bit rates.
Sorry.
I'm going to represent as an ambassador.
Girls make games.
There's a...
Oh.
quality.
Over the past 12 years, Girls Make Games has empowered over
8,000.
All right, 1080.
There you go.
Through summer camps, workshops, and game jams.
Oh.
In 2022, GMG established a college scholarship to bridge the
gap for young women as they entered college and careers.
Did it just, was it just low quality?
Due to their mission statement, the founders of this
incredible organization chose two inspiring members of their
community to accept the award on behalf of girls make games
and i'd like to invite them yeah char like i had yeah i
opened i opened the link to charlie stream and then it it
degraded the quality and monica paredes yeah yep that's
crazy the biggest award of his life yeah and this past
summer you and three friends created a game that won the
grand prize is that right yeah our game is called paper
trail and templus uh templus thank you for tier one
something thank you you draw when you're bored and so humble
man you've made have now come to life instead attacking you
you have to go from room to room solving puzzles in order to
escape and we wanted this game to be creepy but not too
scary so everyone can play well what great opportunity for
her next for paper trail soon we're going to start working
with professionals to fully publish our game on steven
playstation that's cute that's a huge accomplishment for
someone so young i'm personally super excited to see the
prototype we made at camp turn into a full-fledged game
especially for like yeah it's like it's literally a game jam
daughter because she is actually the brave scary girl games
girl not me um i like to play cozy games and grow virtual
turnips do you have turnips in your game um you can look on
that um so monica your journey is a little bit different
with gmg um you never went to the camp but you actually were
one of the recipients girl this is a scary game we ain't
growing anything so i grew up loving video games she's like
did you die here this is a scary puzzle game my high school
robotics teacher actually encouraged me to apply for the
scholarship he knew I was interested in game development
then I got it now I'm attending USC and I've been doing some
game development you're not a child I've actually had some
game development experience with our club there open alpha
at USC it's amazing it sounds like it's really helped you
set you up for success is there any message that you'd like
to give girls out there who might dream of making their own
video games one day yeah I think if you're someone out there
with an interest in making give you a video game.
I didn't even have a robotics program.
You never know where that interest could take you, and
there's a ton of amazing programs, like girls make games,
who want to see you succeed.
Yeah, well, obviously, I really wish that they had been in
an organization like this when I was a kid, but I'm very
excited that starting next year, my eight-year-old daughter
can go to GMG and express her love of gaming.
You guys are very inspirational.
Thank you.
I have a grudge.
I didn't get to grow up with this.
It's not fair.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
What?
Congratulations and a huge thanks to Monica Perez and Ellie
Bowen for accepting on behalf of GMG.
Yay.
Yeah.
Is this what the kids say these days?
Do you think?
Thank you so much.
Am I hit with the children?
Congratulations to girls games.
It's an incredible program.
I've had the chance to visit their summer camps in the past
and it is truly inspiring See the passion and the creativity
that these young developers bring to the medium initiatives
like that don't just open doors I still oh my gosh if you
guys didn't know Overwatch released a new update to soldier
76 called the soldier 67 When he says sick where you can
have an emote where he literally says six seven and then
people are like what do like so people are getting emoted by
soldier players now like soldiers like kill someone and then
do like six seven like emotes six seven on them and people
like and then people are supposed to be like what the do i
do do i just uninstall or do what they're like what the do i
do now do i uninstall this game i've heard a dozen tales
that say you're unstoppable
Year-wise, Soldier is a Gen Alpha.
For those who don't know, Overwatch is said in the future.
And Soldier 76 was technically...
It's technically boring when Gen Alpha was a thing.
So he grew up with 6-7.
Oh hey, there's Lara Croft.
Yeah, it's a lore-accurate meme.
So he's reciting the old memes in Overwatch.
No, it's Lord Akron.
And it's fucking hilarious, though.
Because people are like, do I...
What do I do?
Do I undersell the game?
Do I fucking kill myself in Minecraft?
The fuck if I...
Must be tough getting emoted like that.
Story
began.
And everything changed.
And this is on Game Studios.
Guys, I...
Oh, that's tough.
That's rough.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I sort of... I don't know.
I don't know.
It's by Amazon Games, guys.
Like, that's rough, buddy.
And for that reason, I'm out.
This is pre-rendered, though.
I mean, it looks good.
The thing is, this is pre-rendered.
What the fuck is your dinosaurs doing in my lark?
I can't believe Lara killed off the dinosaurs.
I've always been dinosaurs.
I didn't grow up with Lara craft games.
So I wasn't aware that dinosaurs existed in the games.
I mean, I know dinosaurs are real.
But you know what I mean?
I didn't know they were in the games.
I didn't play Lara.
I didn't play Tomb Raider.
That's my dad played Tomb Raider.
I didn't.
All I know about Tomb Raider are the triangle boobs.
There you have it.
Not one, but two Tomb Raider.
Two!
That's crazy.
Legacy of Atlantis, a reimagining of Lara's iconic debut
from 1996.
Yeah, I'm the deny.
Yeah, it's like it's like how I think the it's like how I
think the earth is flat Panthers aren't real and the earth
is flat guys Completely unexpected VR.
Yeah, that's definitely unexpected.
I said is this a VR game?
It looks like a VR game.
I mean he did say completely unexpected
I don't like I don't think they're letting just and roll and
make another game or like or like invite him to the game
awards is this a vr extraction shooter oh no they're coming
in vr now
what the fuck i mean she think though it's all about the
bottom half oh she has one boob Hmm.
It might be a deal breaker.
Boob is a boob.
Yeah, she's missing half the...
Oh, Force 3.
Hi, I'm Robert Kirkman, co-creator of Invincible.
And I'm here to introduce a brand new character.
Yeah, is that the Force?
Oh, hey.
Hey, Robbie Kay.
I got this.
Oh, is this a fighting game?
Love what you've done with the place.
Rex, I was just here to introduce a world premiere.
Look, I am the world premiere.
You're supposed to be dead.
Cue the orchestra.
Cue the seething jealousy.
Oh, God.
Second.
Best character in our 3v3.
What happened to the animation budget?
What the fuck?
I said roll it, Kirkman.
Spoilers.
He's not dead, Stokey.
See, he's right here.
You don't know my name now, but you will once this is over.
uh who is she she may be some minor earth hero yeah wait who
is she is elemental wait she's not was she in the comics
yeah i don't remember her in the comics
what yeah yeah she's the avatar Yeah, that's a completely
new character.
She was not in the comics.
I was like, I wish I don't remember her.
What the fuck?
But there's so many...
I guess it's because, like, majority of the characters
invincible is just...
Are all Superman?
So they're like, we gotta have a new character?
I mean...
Nintendo Switch 2.
Oh, just...
Oh, so it comes...
So it's from Nintendo.
so is it from nintendo yeah i'm gonna say like like majority
of characters in invincible oh shit wait what the art style
is this space land
oh my god space is sand land too in space Oh, it's like...
Um, it takes two, but anime.
It's literally, it takes two anime.
Yeah.
Orbitos.
It takes anime.
Yeah, it looks like it takes two.
Does not look fun.
A two-player co-op game starring Maki and Omura with a retro
anime universe aesthetic.
orbitals is coming in 2026 now it's time to present some
other Jeff Jeff yes Piggy oh miss Piggy Rolf the dog yes my
accompaniness my my companion is yeah I thought she's gonna
announce something now you know we're actually live in the
middle of the show Piggy we have awards we have
announcements you know what Go with this guy.
Where's Kermit?
It's right for later in the show, okay?
Oh my God, it's like I miss Piggy.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Announce the affair.
He already did announce the affair.
It's going to work out.
Rall's probably just stuck in traffic.
It's okay, Piggy.
It's okay.
All right.
More of that later.
Now we're here to honor another...
Oh, imagine she announced Game of the Year.
Here are the nominees for best action adventure game.
Death Stranding 2 on the beach.
Ghost of Yote.
Hollow Knight's Silk Song.
It should be on.
It should be Silk Song, right?
Split Fiction.
Yeah.
The game award goes to Hollow Knight's Silk Song.
I mean...
You guys won.
All right, here are the nominees for Best Art Correct.
Guys, I think that's the only award they're going to win.
Guys.
80s 2 and Hollow Knight Silk Saw And the Game Award Guys
Claire obscure Oh Guys That's not good That he said That
might be the only game They're gonna win Jurassic World
Evolution 3 Sid Meier Civilization 7 Tempest Rising See we
gave you one I don't know why did he say it like that Final
fantasy tactics oh yeah it's Jurassic World Evolution got
nominated oh blueprints it has to be clear obscure oh my god
it's actually a e3 3 sweet and the game award goes to clear
obscure expedition 33 yeah it's literally e3 3 sweet we'll
have much more game awards ahead but right now here's a
first official reveal of Wurthering Waves 3.0 coming on
Christmas Day and a nominee tonight for both players voice
and best mobile game.
Oh, that's fucked up.
Like whenever anyone says like, see, you guys got one, that
means it's the only one.
Usually it's the only award.
So, this trip's theme is back to school, huh?
Welcome to Star Torch Academy.
Squaring Ways?
Yeah, I heard, like, I mean, I heard it's still very popular
in its, like, in the genre it is in.
I think Silk Song, it's just unfortunate that Silk Song
released around the time that...
I think it's... I think everybody expected Silk Song to be
released.
really good but no one expected like like uh e33 e33 to come
out like no one because the e33 was like a game that came
out of nowhere almost well not nowhere but like no one
really had like super high expectations about it because it
was a debut game so then like so obviously like uh it was
very unexpected so more people are like more hyped about it
because of how they didn't expect it to like expect it at
all but soxon everyone had high expectations about it
Yeah, and there was a lot of competition too
I also hope that Claire had a really good soundtrack too The
most valuable jewel in the game Earn them by playing the
stuff you love I heard about the soundtrack from Claire.
Score the latest IRL swag.
Or up your game with limited edition merch.
Victory is yours and so are rewards.
No, I haven't played it because it's a...
I know the type of game, the game genre, it doesn't match
like my playstyle.
It's not the type of game I know I would like enjoy as much
as like the other people would.
What's this?
This power?
Oh, is this the Yen-Cin power?
Oh, it's...
Oh, wait, it's...
It's another power.
Nope, it's the other one.
There's so many powers.
Wait, which power is this?
I've lost track.
Eternal, thank you for tier one sub, thank you, thank you.
Animo.
It's a new power.
Oh.
This reminds me of that country star that did like a fucking
satanic, like, visuals for a country song in the sphere.
Was this Diablo?
streamers are no better me you've corrupted more minds than
even i not me i i'm innocent yay
impressive as for the rest of you who of you is worthy of
facing me he didn't call me out guys lord of hatred and you
are nothing oh
What the fuck?
Oh, I knew it is Diablo.
It looked very Diablo-esque with his eye.
I mean, the design itself was very Diablo.
Um, no, no, no.
He didn't call me out.
He called out Shroud.
Is this a Diablo DLC?
Please be for mobile.
Oh shit, that's hardcore bro.
What happens when you kill a demon?
Don't they just revive themselves back in hell?
Oh!
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
God.
Despite like, you know, everything that's happened with
Blizzard games, their cinematics are still like so good.
Yeah, the cinematics are still- Oh!
Prepare for the reckoning!
Honestly, I- I wish they would like pivot to animation.
I missed the Overwatch Cinematics.
See you look, it's TLC.
Want to know who else is here?
Well, it's time for an update from Marvel Rivals, a nominee
tonight.
The best ongoing game about the latest Marvel hero set to
join the game in 2026.
How did she do it, guys?
He's trying to blast my ass if you know he won't.
I got a surprise for her.
She has the script.
This is gonna be fun.
Get her.
The MDA dokey.
I'm the one who set you free.
Oh, hey, this was not the plan.
Okay, guys, guys.
The only reason I knew that it was Deadpool was because
Deadpool was was released on December 11th and guess what
day is it today
it was so obvious
Donkey Kong was gonna fucking get you
I'm sorry I don't have that
That's unfortunate.
They couldn't get someone that sounded like Ryan Reynolds.
Yeah!
Right.
She's my rival.
Night at museum.
I don't know that.
Wait, is he wearing a fucking vest?
Please welcome actress, producer, and activist.
Also, like, also they leaked Deadpool and that other girl in
the update.
Like, they were like, oh, they leaked it out.
him to be next for the new season i have the pleasure of
playing dr selena so no devs got in trouble there was no nta
breach guys some might say daring habit of crossing paths
with rather dashing antagonists and this one is undoubtedly
unforgettable glennie thank you for the tier one stuff thank
you thank you rats they give us here one so thank you thank
you i don't trust you and debbie They're like, dude, you're
a Deadpool.
I only get the OG skins.
I'm not really a fan of the Deadpool skin.
I am sometimes asked, Bovma, how is it that you hear every
whisper in every corner of Aleph?
Check Vlad?
My answer, I built Aleph with my will, my blood, my whole
self.
is an extension of my being my body today it became infected
oh shit oh not jack black yeah okay he sounded like jack
black there for a second oh hey it's a james bond name
please welcome he sounded like jack black for a little
Yeah, he got excited about, he got, Dad got excited about
Deadpool and Lenny Kravitz.
Bro, he looks just like him.
Good evening.
Was a great honor to be asked to join 007, first light from
my first voyage into the world of video games.
Who is this guy, by the way?
He's like, who is he?
A wild, unpredictable pirate ruler of Africa's greatest
black market hub.
I knew I was stepping into something special.
Oh, he's a musician.
We all see chaos.
Bubba sees freedom.
He rose from nothing, made free, and built his own kingdom
of Aleph.
And his story is just beginning.
Every world we build needs the power of rhythm through
music.
These musicians can turn violence into beauty and silence
into tension.
Also, how many songs?
Here are the nominees for Best Score and Music.
Okay, so we've only had like one performance for this.
You know, usually they do like everything, you know, every,
all the, the nominees get like a performance then it was
just one.
I expected like the other performances too.
Yeah, it's E3.
I think it's...
Welcome back, E3.
And the game award goes to...
Welcome back.
I didn't expect you to come back like this.
La Rian Testaro.
See, E3 eventually came back guys.
Thank you so much.
We are so happy to be here tonight.
It was incredible to play in the HTML in live with you.
It's incredible.
Thank you so much.
I might get that in here.
I have a letter.
I would love to read.
So we,
I would really love to start by thinking all the musicians
who work on the soundtrack with us, who give their soul and
their hand and their voice to the sound of the music.
I also want to thank you, Alice, to standing by my side.
All right, he's on my lap.
Say it's because I'm not playing game.
Anyone just watching?
So it's five.
Thank you for having each note through within you.
and for letting Alicia's voice is that's here now I can
bring him here thank you, Guillaume never mind
he's in here in spirit and thank you to all my loved one for
their love and their support during all this technically
here and to all our players thank you for letting Claire
Obscure and our music find a place inside you You are the
Lumiere that make us want to keep painting, keep loving, and
keep dreaming.
Thank you for reaching out your hands to us.
You can almost see the screen, yeah.
Can you see that?
Can you see it?
Thank you.
To the untreated tomorrow.
Oh, I thought you said translate that in French too.
I would like to say something too.
to receive this award tonight it's a wonderful recognition
of our work over the past five years wait they wrote this on
the music sheet oh my i think they didn't think they're
gonna win and then like and then they're like oh wait we're
sweeping the words wait we gotta write a speech now quick
tomorrow comes i'm pretty that's like literally a music
sheet right there
members can go to amazon.com slash the game awards to save
up to 25 on select gaming hardware and accessories from
brand turtle beach lenovo samsung and more well thanks
amazon from warframe community director megan everett and
creative director rebecca ford are you dead hello game you
can't even see the screen anyway How many registered users
is Warframe at?
No, that's an inside joke for Warframe.
Twitch chat, Megan.
All right.
Hi, Twitch chat.
Hi, Game Awards.
We're here for Warframe.
We launched our biggest update of the year, the old piece,
just yesterday.
And all things considered, the update went smooth.
So we're not here to finally announce that we're coming out
of open beta 12 years later.
No, we're still in beta, 12 years.
They're still in beta?
In those 12 years.
Bro, time off is out.
Bro, this dark cop has an ending now.
I know in Warframe and now Envoys with Soulframe and we
truly wouldn't be here without them.
So Reb, why are we actually here?
We are here to outsource the question of what is Warframe.
We have completely given up answering it ourselves.
Warframe was once ninjas in space, which it still is.
It's a running joke.
And we climb to the tagline, 12 years.
It's time to let a legend tell you what is Warframe.
Namus, thank you for gifting us up.
Thank you, thank you.
Potato.
What is Warframe?
Yeah, what is Warframe?
I've never played Warframe before.
Is it like Destiny?
Oh, I might have said, I might have triggered some Warframe
people.
I'm sorry, I don't, I've never played Warframe before.
Guys, I might be...
I'm not rage baiting, I swear.
Don't keep it.
I swear to God, it's not rage bait.
I know, like, destiny and warframe players hate each other.
What drives them?
Their residual instinct or some separate conscious force?
force we may not know but there's one who does they hear her
voice a blanket against the horror they insist blindly upon
humanity and its worth even in the face of ultimate
indifference But with so little understanding of what they
have.
It's fine.
I hate them.
To me.
Tenno.
Wake up.
Oh, it's Destiny of It's Free.
That's Warframe.
Wait, people still talk about this series?
However, the book of stars.
Didn't they like, what was this?
The Seven Deadly Sins, right?
Didn't they fuck up?
Of the anime?
Yeah.
I really like fell off super hard.
Now, a new destiny calls to us.
For the new tale we are about to create.
This reminds me of...
Together we run.
Bound by destiny.
The style reminds me of level 7.
A co-op open world RPG for everyone.
the seven deadly sins origin
who the fuck has six friends we're gonna find 600 people to
play seven deadly sins
oh yeah they said there's gonna be a free game where's my
free game epic jeff told me i'm gonna have a free game on
the epic store where the fuck is my free game by the way you
can use my code dokey bird for fortnite items they're gonna
make a 6-7 emote in fort sorry guys kim kardashian is in
fortnite now guys oh
fantasy is free on the epic game store right now and there's
even more Harry Potter fun coming later this month guys guys
you guys here anyway you guys here that Kim Kardashian is
important the monkey frog girl it's the world we live in
guys all right back in 2023 Lawrence of the Fallen surprise
surprise real combat dark fantasy world building and
stunning dual realm design Tonight, we have your first ever
look at the gameplay of the sequel.
They brought back boobs.
They brought back boobs in Fortnite, guys.
Apparently, like, I didn't know this, but in Fortnite, they
had to censor all the boobs when it got more and more
popular with the kids.
So they, like, redesigned a lot of the skins that showed
boobs.
Because Kim Kardashian is now the first only official skin
where it shows boobs, where it shows cleavage.
Oh.
What?
Where's my...
Hello?
Where'd my stream go?
Oh, there we go.
A baby in a donkey.
No matter the cost.
What happened to the music?
The music is a little weird, isn't it, right?
What the fuck?
Forgive me.
Yeah, but her talking isn't fucking buffered.
Lords of the Fallen, version 2.5, with new veteran mode out
today.
No, I think it's like to be like not caught.
This next set of awards recognizes diverse set of games
across a variety of genres.
I think it was Twitch being like, okay, we don't want to get
striked by music producers.
So they like, they like tuned out to, they like retuned it
or some shit.
racing cross worlds and the game award goes to Mario Kart
world yeah I'm not surprised here are the nominees for best
community support Baldur's Gate 3 Final Fantasy 14 there'll
be no man's sky right and no man's sky this year the game
award goes to Baldur's Gate 3 oh that's your name Mika okay
who's voting for this Deadpool VR and the Midnight Walk the
game award goes to the Midnight Walk Midnight Walk okay I'm
gonna refresh this the nominees for best role-playing game
okay we okay there's not a competition that's not a that's
not a competition at all and the Outer Worlds 2 this year
the game award for RPG goes to I wonder who alright I'm
gonna refresh this just just to be sure they're obscure
Expedition 33 Dispatch Ancient Impact Hollow Knight Silk
Song and Wurthering Waves this year the fans selected What
the fuck What's going on Wurthering Waves as the winner What
All right And now We've got something great for you Please
welcome actor Rahul Kohli People Real Guys Look, people
really wanted their free currency, guys.
Free currency has won.
Guys, but imagine all the free currency you can get in
withering waves now.
Imagine.
For the last 30 years, the housemark name has been
synonymous with ring action.
They need those rolls.
Of course, bullet hell.
It's been an honor working with them, not just as an actor.
but as a fan of Stardust, Returnal, imagine all the polls
they can get now.
Fuel to play when Sarus lands next year.
And here's the debut of our new story trailer.
How do I get rid of this?
Now it's fucking bullying me about the fucking co-streaming
thing.
I don't want to co-stream.
I just don't know how.
Why, person, they even tier one sub.
Thank you.
boy all right if i click it i'm gonna have to do this you're
gonna have to listen to this but it still shows up it's
trying to tell me to co-stream since the last time the sun
died mate he's telling me it's like we've left a fear we've
lost people there's there's no way to get home
It gets in our heads And it twists Is Returnal?
I mean, it looks like it Yeah, it is It's Returnal I will
not Learn the code stream
This Returnal is basically Returnal is actually really fun I
just wish it wasn't If it wasn't like a PlayStation 5
exclusive I think this game would have been more popular
It's just unfortunate It was a PS5 exclusive That like
basically Oh That basically like killed the hype
Oh, it's not returner No returner is now on PC, but yeah,
what I meant like if it started as a If it started on PC it
would have been more hype That's what I'm trying to say
Grand Theft Auto 3, 4, 5 Oh San Andreas Red Dead Redemption
Look at that trailer co-founder of Rockstar Games and now
the founder of a new studio, Absurd Ventures, where he is
busy writing and creating novels, comic books, animated
series, and yes, two big upcoming unannounced open-world
games.
It is my honor to welcome you to the stage for the first
time an industry icon, Dan Houser.
Oh my God, Dan Houser!
Oh, I can co-stream it!
Guys, I'm going to co-stream.
Give me a sec, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, okay, this is gonna be a bit scabbed.
I'm gonna do it.
I did it!
Good evening.
I'm co-streaming!
You guys don't have figured it out?
I'll show you guys.
More than any other medium, video games have the power to
take the audience on a journey both physically and
emotionally.
Games don't just tell us a story and let us live it.
The story becomes the experience driven and shared by the
player's choices it's a level of shared authorship that's
unique i bet it was a single button it wasn't a turkey and
so here are the nominees for best narrative best narrative i
said it guys i learned how this ghost dream it was a mistake
i will find every last number of the years it wasn't there
before every Russian has showed up.
Guys, I'm part of the crew now.
I'm part of the cool kids group.
E33.
Gojumbo's like, just, gojumbo's just like, bro.
I gotta get these guys in the studio to sign my board.
He's gonna get Charlie Cox in the studio now And what's her
name the the girl who played mad
But Jumbo's gonna get Charlie Cox and the that girl in the
studio now
They're stacking the discount codes
Guys Thank you to our Oh my god, the discount code for the
next trailer for next year is going to be so cheap for them.
In games, a story is a shared creation.
It starts with words on a page, but the player experiences
it through the work of each of our teams.
What the fuck is the XQC snooze?
Oh, it's because they're sweeping.
I like how that theme of that's flying onto my screen.
And through localization into other languages.
All of that is supported by our producing.
and our technical teams.
The last ingredient is our players who interpret the story
in the context of their own lives and who keep our story
alive through their own creative expression and discussions.
The marvelous thing about games is that we create that
experience together, our team with our players.
Thank you so much.
Yeah!
what the fuck why did he bring the picture book oh wait it's
like the the thing that says his name i was like why is
there a picture book with a 12-month play pass and travel
case next i have the honor of announcing a world premiere
now thank you for gifting a tier one sub to jagoon collector
timmy thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you
this is law no law port desire a city that don't belong to
anyone but everyone wants a piece no law i'm gonna say it no
oversight just the jungle creepy a lot of not a lot of very
hype game announcements this year the mayor i will say it
said the city needed order and they'd be the ones to bring
it it's on their turn for you you.
Dirt instead of blood.
But desire is a fickle mistress.
The city won't let me go.
It won't forget my name.
I asked for nothing, and they still came and took
everything.
The mares and anyone that stands in my way, every last one
of them.
They're gonna learn real simple what game is this this is an
abstraction shooter okay no it's just park it's just parkour
no love i i guess it's just an fps single player shooter and
good morning to everyone in uh sweden and uh europe i know
it's a late night we got a lot more show for you but coming
up we've got more awards like best game direction to present
that from bethesda and more announcements the longest game
awards with the least amount of substance right now game
awards get ready to get on your feet earlier this year
netflix's devil may cry brought capcom's iconic game
franchise to life as an exceptional animated series
nominated tonight not todd the show also featured a number
one single from our next
afterlife, please welcome Evanescence.
Wait, but they already not won the music awards.
Don't believe his sweet little lies.
Oh, that's sad.
This is the first time anyone's ever seen clips of this
show.
Oh,
This is the most viewership this show has ever got.
Bye-bye, darling.
Yeah, it started so many cries.
Yeah,
I know the out-of-wake performance is like the best it'll
ever do.
I don't think there's any performance that can top that.
Just like a Sonic game, at least the music is good.
True!
Gameplay can be mediocre, but we can always count on the
music.
I don't know.
The anime did not deserve this soundtrack i think the entire
budget went to the fucking music at this point
whoa you go girl you guys know blizzcon is back brought
blizzcon back
Yeah.
Why?
No, I'm like thinking like, they don't really have a lot of
games anymore that people talk about.
So good.
Talk about a performance.
Devil May Cry season two.
Like no one really plays Herbstone anymore.
Everybody's doing team fight tactics.
I guess the only game that's sort of alive is Overwatch.
And...
I guess Diablo?
The Game Awards Orchestra are tuning up.
Oh, wow.
Okay, I forgot about World of Warcraft for some reason.
I think it says MM...
I think like MMOs are now so like...
Not, you know, it's not as popular.
anymore.
Oh, is that the...
What is it called?
We're moon mates?
Yeah.
People were saying it's crazy that this game is free.
Because of like the quality of gameplay.
Yeah, apparently the gotcha is only for the clothes, for the
outfits.
Like it's just cosmetics for the gotcha.
Everything else is free.
Yeah, people are like, it's way too good to be free.
I've heard about it.
Literally just got, like, cosmetics are the only thing
that's paid.
Oh, where win meets.
Yeah, the cosmetics are apparently really expensive.
Is this Phasmophobia?
Oh, why does it look so different?
Why does that look different than the PC version?
They'll want to play other games they love too.
So you'll build them a place to discover more cool games.
More than that.
Perfect.
But then they want to play those games anywhere and
everything.
Yeah, that did not look like the same game.
Yeah, was there a big fucking update or something?
And everything else they love in one place.
So you'll give them a U-Tap, a home base that tracks all
their play, no matter how they play, with one souped up
profile to rule them all.
Also, I saw some here were mentioning about AI dialogue.
I think a lot of people forget that our creators also use AI
dialogue as well.
47.
An urgent threat has emerged in Dartmoor.
One that can have catastrophic consequences on a global
scale.
We don't forget.
Please welcome the actress behind Hitman's next elusive
target, Mila Yovavitch.
Yeah, at least, yeah, the voice actors get paid at least,
yeah.
It's like how, what's his name?
It's like how Darth Vader, the voice of Darth Vader sold his
soul and voice to Disney.
And then we had, we had...
And then we had Darth Vader in Fortnite being very, very
racist.
as the next elusive target in yeah uh the guy the voice
actor for darf ador sold his voice to disney and now it's
used for ai the hunt he's dead by the way that's like i
think that was like the worst part he's dead and he sold his
voice to disney modern multiplayer represents a monstrous
challenge in game or his family sold his voice that's sadder
that's even more sad that account for the of thousands of
live opponents?
Or even worse, the persistent dumbness of a human teammate?
It's no easy task.
And tonight's nominees all pull it off in their own
inspiring way.
Here they are.
Best multiplayer game.
They said the world above had ended.
Wait, who's the award presenter?
Oh, I think it's Art Reader who's gonna win.
to be our creators.
It's literally, it started so many people's, it started and
also revived a shitload of people's careers.
Oh, the Resident Evil actress.
Wow.
Like, a lot of people's streamer careers got revitalized and
also started in our careers with our creators.
Who do you want?
all right all right all right all right all right i got it
right here please pick beak for big bug
yeah i'm not surprised it had to be that shit is popular
with the normies
it's so bloom yo i i was still so surprised to find out
they're the same creators of the finals too.
That's a good extraction shooter.
Wow.
Arc and Finals are both good.
First of all, thank you all.
Haunted, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Rise, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Drag knock.
Thank you for the gift of tier oneself for Kachina.
Kachina.
Go and shoot.
Cheering us on along the way.
Embark Studios as a whole.
you get one for the fearless leadership of our dear Patrick
Sutherland the partners in Nexon whose unwavering trust in
us took us all the way here and made it all possible I mean
I'm not surprised the players whose love and engagement just
means the world to us thank you all I heard the East team
for the finals is like really popular too even though like
the game itself is not alive in nane i know the game is very
alive in asia you know i'm from the marvel cinematic
universe and stranger things please welcome to the game
awards david harbour
who is david harbour Oh, the cop in Stranger Things.
What the fuck does he play in Marvel?
Yeah, he's the policeman in Stranger Things, right?
For 25 years, creative assembly has entertained millions of
people all around the world with the Total War franchise.
Oh my god.
Today, I'm here to help announce where Total War is going
next.
And it'll be in a universe that is so close.
Oh, one of the hell boys.
I'm excited to reveal that Total War is headed to the grim
dark future.
Oh, he's Captain Russia.
Warhammer 40K.
Captain Russia.
Some of you may know this, but some of you may not know
this, but I am a huge fan of tabletop gaming.
I've painted endless miniatures, spent a crazy amount of
time dropping dice under a table.
Of course, as you might expect, I'll be in the game.
Whoa.
It'll be in the game.
It connects to some of my favorite aspects.
of the universe.
Quite expensive, huh?
Bro, that guy is a movie actor.
He has...
Let's take a first look at Total War.
Warhammer.
He has the money.
That guy was in the New Avengers.
He has minifigures money.
Brothers!
Literally the only thing I know about the Warhammer series.
That and Flash Kids.
Thank you for everything I learned about Warhammer is from
Flash Kids.
Brothers.
Across countless worlds, battles rage.
How dare you say that, but the Emperor?
Look, they're just trying to keep their bloodline clear.
From the goddamn aliens.
For the Emperor.
They don't have a bloodline.
They're close.
That makes their bloodline extra close.
If they keep cloning themselves, there won't be any.
Oh, what?
Wait, is this a RTS?
Wait, this is a real-time strategy game.
It's total war.
There's no peace among us.
the stars oh
my god we'll bring back RTS guys I didn't think I lived to
see the dead especially with everyone so much with so much
ADHD in our generation or not our gender in the feed in gen
alpha will it truly survive in the current generation take a
look what a sight to behold It's all over.
The last lands of the FCU.
The Federation of Central Yusha.
Oh?
First of all, thank you for joining us on this ship.
Hello there, my dear newcomer.
You are very lucky, you know.
Yes, we are critically under command on this ship.
Don't worry at all.
Oh my god, is this Top Gun?
I never watched Top Gun.
The only thing I know about Top Gun is from family guy
because they keep referencing top gun and i watch family guy
unironically okay i guess i'll never know it's just 2 hd
guys
it's 2 hd what can i say
To keep up alive, Wings of Thief must stay on the mission.
Must fly on.
I can make up your killer.
Fine.
From now on, you'll be the greatest ace pilot this war will
ever be.
Oh my god.
Like, uh, Ace Combat?
Wings of Thief.
Never played Ace Combat before.
Oh, there's a lot of passionate Ace Combat fans there.
Yes, that's right.
Ace Combat is back in 20...
add the sound effects of people clapping there was no one
clapping in the audience guys i did not see anyone clapping
i was clapping it was just one person clapping some of the
key folks behind burnout and need for it was off camera
experiencing experience I think they actually inputted a
sound effect.
I did not see anyone in the audience clapping there.
Is this pod racing?
Wait, this is pod racing.
Now this is pod racing.
Yeah, I remember.
Recognize the pods.
Unskilled.
Thank you for the five gifted souls.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Did that guy just shot him?
Holy shit.
This looks intense.
I do not think this is gameplay trailer though.
Galactic Racer Oh hey it's that guy I'm curious how the
gameplay trailer is gonna look though What the fuck is it
buffering a lot today
Oh I remember I saw the trailer for this What were your
names again?
I remember this They literally made this entire game out of
stock motion which is crazy yeah that's a lot of effort it's
a feeling it's a feeling of destiny follow me apparently
stop motion is cheaper than 3d animation but it's i feel
like i don't know it's crazy because i feel like the effort
of stop motion is a lot more i'm gonna have to refresh this
though because the music's fucked up again yeah it's
definitely more labor intensive I remember I saw a trailer
for this such a beautiful game that was out of words a stop
motion co-op game being developed it's another day it takes
two and now I'd like to welcome back an icon a legend who
pushes entertainment forward with each of their new projects
someone I consider a dear friend and a friend of the show
miss piggy oh my god wait is she actually gonna announce
game of the year i am so sorry not kojima oh no kojima got
bumped to number two because of my accompanist this dog was
late as usual hey sorry i lost track of time i was out
taking myself for a walk
She got replaced by Miss Piggy.
Let's go.
It's time for you to sing, Pig.
Sing?
Sing what?
We haven't rehearsed anything.
Jeff has a new best friend.
Yeah, wouldn't fit my hatchback.
Listen, what are you worried about?
You know, we'll just, we'll wing it.
Wing it?
Sure.
Who knows?
Maybe it'll all work out.
How about something like this?
in a world where gaming games are so exciting uh waiting all
year long until the time will come your turn what i can't
just make up any words without some meaning pretty good this
is stupid this whole thing is really dumb hey you got it so
if you're looking for some friends just stick around oh yes
the game awards will never let you down good luck excuse me
as we all know that's not true Tokyo to London, we're all
watch inside myself.
So if you're looking for some fun, the time is now.
Oh, yes, the Game Awards will never let you down.
Yeah, we'll see.
It's a night to watch our online chats, Gabor.
Exactly.
To shame that host, Jeff Keely said, Game Awards always let
you down.
The daily rigs.
Don't forget about all of them.
Oh, boy.
I'm getting so excited about this wonderful world of gaming.
Well, here's some awesome titles you simply It's used to
score it?
You mean the names of all the games that I'll be playing?
Yeah, now let's get ready.
Let's get set.
You guys keep score.
What a marvin.
Oh, there's Mario Minecraft Legend of Zelda.
Nominee Donkey Kong Bonanza.
Kingdom Archieke, shovel 9, Fortnite.
Overcooked Tomb Raider, Anton Madachi Life.
Indiana Jones, Marva Robles, and Sandbuf.
All guys have come.
Oh, my God.
Marvel Rivals is canon in the Muppets.
Oh, wow, I didn't have to do that.
A two, three.
So when I'm Prince's Beach, wearing Christmas boots.
It's Kevin!
See, the Game Awards will always let you down!
That's crazy.
You mean there's more games than E33?
Piggy and Ralph the Dog.
It all worked out in the end for them.
Alright, the Gamer Wars will be right back after this new
look at Do It Night Abyss.
The Gamer Wars always lets me down.
I can't believe it.
It's from that song that I learned the existence of other
games.
I thought it was... I swear to God, I thought there was only
one game that was released this year.
And it was Claire E33.
You could have fooling me.
The 33 in the game name stands for how many awards is gonna
win in the game awards.
Bro, they just have to drop a DLC next year.
The moment they drop a DLC in 2026, then they can sweep that
one too.
I know I'm buff.
Why is buffering a lot?
Maybe I'll just, I could lower the quality a little bit
more, maybe.
No, I don't want to watch in 720.
I have fiber!
It shouldn't be buffering.
I think it's because so many people are watching it.
I don't think Twitch was anticipating how many people were
watching the Game Rewards this year.
Yeah, I'm refreshing.
Yeah, I think it's just the server is getting hammered.
I'm refreshing it guys because it started doing the thingy
where the music is oh hey AMD I
think I remembered oh yeah we went on YouTube guys remember
we went on YouTube last year because twitch kept buffering I
remember now yeah I think it's just twitch things but like
now we're buffering later
I forgot about that Yeah, I was one of five people watching
from YouTube
This is Ark Knights
What is the best part?
I don't know, this year is like This is the longest game
This is the longest game award so far But I feel like least
amount of content this year.
Also, it doesn't help that one game is just sweeping
everything, so it's pretty boring.
I think that it's just too predictable.
I think my favorite was Moist Critical's reaction for
winning content creator of the year.
And all he said was, yep.
Yep.
Thanks, chat.
No, it's just we're so like, you know, when you know what's
gonna happen, there's no like tension or be like, oh guys,
who's gonna win this?
Like it's so predictable who's gonna win what?
So it's like, it's not, you're not even like, there's no,
like yeah, it's cool, they won, but like it's so
predictable.
There's no like variety of like what to expect.
There's just no competition.
It's like sports sometimes when one team just sweeps it all
in the end because it's just really boring because it's so
predictable the games aren't like super like intense or
anything that was the announcement of yeah there's no
suspense a new song with arc night endfield which arrives
january 22nd 2026 and then like a lot of the trailers that
dropped not there hasn't been game for i mean i think
there's like i think just the games only for you here at the
yeah i think it says like a lot of Also, games are not,
like, my type of genre that I like to play.
I think for other people...
Wait, is this...
Oh, never mind.
I was like, oh my god, is he wall-riding, like, Titanfall?
But then I'm like, that's funny.
Doki.
Titanfall is dead.
EA got bought by Saudi Arabia.
For one second.
Whoa.
But yeah, like, I think it says, like, a lot of games they
announce aren't, like, genres that I tend to play.
So I'm not like...
For me, it feels like a lot of the announcements have been,
like, lackluster.
Other than the First Republic, that one was...
That one was cool.
I like that.
All right, let's get on.
I'm gonna put...
Let Dad out.
Oh, never mind.
He's just sitting in the...
Never mind.
He's just sitting in his bed now.
There's always a last game trailer and the first one.
That's the most hype.
Or the Old Republic.
I mean, this one's cool.
Is this like... Is this Souls?
Is this a Souls?
I mean, it's not obvious it's not souls like i mean i meant
like is this souls like
hey surprise extraction shooter i imagine i imagine this was
an extraction shooter oh he wants to get out all right
that's open the door for him it's cool though that we're
seeing a lot of games based off of Chinese history and
folklore.
I like that, though.
I'm getting a lot of it.
Ever since Wukong.
Oh, he's using the drunken style.
Oh, no.
That's the lion dance.
A lot of people misconstrued the lion dance as dragons, but
they're lions.
And they like to eat cabbages.
Why cabbages?
I don't know.
I don't know about...
Sorry, someone in my comment.
Okay.
I'm not gonna read the comment out, but that was a funny
comment.
This is Phantom Blade.
I'm not gonna read it.
I don't know about white cabbages.
I cannot wait to play that on PlayStation and PC when it
comes out next September.
I was just not expecting that.
That was just out of nowhere.
From the Elder Scrolls to Fallout, his games have helped
define our industry and shape the way we explore digital
work.
Please welcome the studio head and creative director at
Bethesda Game Studios.
Don't believe his lies.
But he's real.
If someone told me that Todd Howard was AI, I'd believe
them.
He was AI created by the board.
Todd lied to me more.
True.
The development is the ultimate team sport.
Oh, me lies, Todd.
It doesn't matter if it's a team of 10 or a team of
hundreds.
Art, design, audio, engineering, and marketing, more have to
come together as one game direction is that glue and the
games that have had them all come together well they touch
us can't believe they made this hologram so real guys oh my
god this hologram is crazy real best game direction everyone
vanishes into nothingness
He's just like that student they meet you.
E33.
There's no way E33 doesn't win this.
And the game award goes to Expedition 33.
Oh, there they go again.
That guy looks like one of the college humor guys.
The tall one.
Who would have thought?
Say the whole name tag.
Hello again.
Yeah, this is a quite intimidating.
Wow.
Yeah, what?
Hello, hello.
Let's get to it.
Um, yeah, so back in- How many awards did they win?
I received the mail just anonymously.
uh just yeah make a game they said it would be fun they said
brevi thank you for the tier one something 33.
well well fast forward i've lost count they won 33.
if they won another one they have to change the name to 34.
so don't really understand but you know it's a timeline
however where we're eternally grateful for the support and
love we've received as well um all the was with us to
tonight and the ones abroad, friends and family who believed
in us and made this dream come true.
And yeah, I love to thank my wife as well.
She couldn't make it here tonight, but I think she's
watching it.
She's in Brazil, so time.
What's she doing in Brazil?
Quite huge.
Wait, does she live in Brazil?
Doki, they might live in Brazil.
I was like, what the fuck already?
I was like, you would think they would live in France.
I don't know.
It would become PSP.
Come to Brazil.
I don't know.
I just thought they would be like, they would live in
France.
Especially for those of us who have been playing games for
decades.
Over the years, there have been many games, characters, and
franchises we've all wished would return.
Because come to Brazil.
I hope they'll be ready to announce at an event like this
one one day.
Tonight, I'm excited to share this piece of news with all of
you.
Playing a song that didn't win Music of the Year.
Oh god, the lighting direction was not very smart.
What?
He's me?
Yeah, no, that was a bad choice with the lighting direction.
I do not like that.
Bro, gamers play in the dark.
Why the fuck are you doing this to them?
Bada-da!
What is this?
Mega Man?
Yeah, I was gonna say, the ending was Mega Man.
Yay!
Yeah, I was gonna say, that sounded like Mega Man.
Well, are we getting a new Mega Man game?
my god that
reminds me i need to play mighty number nine
no you don't wait oh my god i can't write that down i need
to remember that i knew there was something i forgot let me
write this down real quick games mighty number nine and even
got a very early glimpse what do you mean 2027 classic 2d
style that they're returning to coming up game yes we can
prepare for mega man 2027 oh nice chris pratt let's go and
jack oh my god i love the prowler sound effect for this is
so funny i'm bowser junior and i'm gonna be taking also why
did they get a grown man, the voice Bowser Jr.
Where's Pat's son?
I don't like the voice for Bowser Jr. He's like, his voice
is deeper than Bowser.
It's weird.
That's it?
That was like 10 seconds more content.
Oh, hey.
What is this?
Yeah, I was like, yay, new trailer!
And it gave us like, not even 10 seconds, like 5 seconds of
new content.
It's just Luigi.
I mean, to be fair, it's Luigi being badass, but still.
Oh my god, it's Neo 33.
Oh, I bet you, Kojumbo is now planning on...
poaching all the actors from from Expedition 33 for Death
Stranding 3 you started hiring them up 5 seconds of Luigi
I'm satisfied this war has an inevitable conclusion Death
Stranding 33
He's like, literally, he's, I feel like, uh, Kojumbo is now
collecting at Hollywood, like, celebrities, like the fucking
Infinity Stones.
Every tweet is just a new celebrity that showed up at his
office.
I'm, I always hear so much about solo leveling.
Is it actually good or is it, like, overhyped?
It's min.
You must have a really good like PR team then or at they
have like a like a lot of advertisement budget No story only
aura.
Ah, it just has good animation, right?
It's Korean sword art online.
Oh, nobody deserves that bro.
Nope No one deserves to be compared to that you
know sometimes our last reveal at the game awards is a
teaser for something years and years away not tonight our
final world premiere comes from 61 members of the team that
built titan fall four years ago the principals founded a new
independent studio with the hopes of pushing the shooter
genre forward with a new original game they've done it in
complete secrecy which is even more amazing because the game
is very deep into development the power of independent
self-published studios to push this medium forward is a
growing and i think positive theme in our industry and so
tonight you're not only going to get the announcement of the
game but also your first look at the gameplay i played it
and after after you see this trailer i think you're going to
want to as well don't with me don't we were laughing about
teddy fox don't fuck with me
No fucking way.
No.
Your light belongs to me.
Moving in for the attack.
Yeah.
She'll break her forming.
It's my turn.
And the coming storm.
And this
is my own.
Pretty crazy.
That's right.
High guard launches in just seven weeks.
Guys, it could be fun.
It is insanely fun to see.
Fun to play as you saw in that trailer.
and now it's time for our final award last year astrobot
take home game of the year and so the tradition goes this
year we're lucky to have that game's director present game
of the year this year from team asobi please welcome nico de
seo guys it's it's free i was mad
good evening or good day wherever you are um this is it
right so let's last year we were blessed with a huge honor
on this very stage um so it is with the great joy oh we're
back today to pass this incredible award it's free another
team guys congratulations to all nominees tonight with your
games traders travel dream sweat love and sometimes very
often cry actually from kids to hardcore gamers there was
truly something for everyone this year i don't know i guess
i expected something else i guess he said tight and far that
did not look like tight and far
the thing is they didn't even show us like war running music
so without further ado Please enjoy the nominations for Game
of the Year courtesy of the Game Awards Orchestra.
Maestro, take it away.
Is he also French?
What's the accent from?
There's no way... Oh, he's back!
He's back, guys!
Oh my god, now they're strong, guys.
it's just the graphics did not look very you know I don't
know oh my god is that transparent trumpet bro oh he's the
only one with a transparent trumpet that guy is extra like
the graphics was just I don't know it just I don't know
Well, you know, it could be fun.
It's free.
Guys, it's...
We can go in with lower expectations.
He's surprised.
Don't you stop?
Stop coping, don't you?
I was just, I was, I, it was a mistake to have, it was a
mistake to have hope for one second.
Yeah, Flutka has a new flute.
Today really was a monkey paw crawl day.
I didn't know why I was like, guys, there's my free episode.
thinking.
Oh my god, the timing for that.
I knew it.
I joked about Titanfall 3.
And then I...
They heard my wish.
Oh, hey!
It's Dunkin' New York lady.
Oh my god, that's a Tommy ass flute
How many flutes does he have oh my god They're getting
bigger
He's alting guys he built up
Guys he alting
Flying i didn't I don't know how to turn the flying emojis
off guys And the game of the year is...
Clare Obscure, Expedition Crane Croix!
Crane Croix!
Guys, I'm sorry, I don't know how to tear the emojis off.
I could have guessed...
No fucking way!
Wow!
Who would have thought?
all right prediction choose oh my god who are the 75 people
that predicted silk song what's guys were hard coping
yes they were on a lot of cope the 75 people it's called
hope i called hope
my heart goes to those copers right now
they saw yeah they saw the veil gambling is dangerous guys
what a weird timeline they cope for so long in silk song
they thought it will work again it was supposed to be a joke
the barrier and not in your eye I have no idea what's
happening well I want to thank first boo it took off the hat
for interactive it's not a full believe he's not full french
exile him from the company i love you guys how dare he bro
so much i gave him his hat fake french
oh my god oh no stereotypes come true i also want to thank
kepler interactive our publisher but also our localization
teams our playtester are wonderful cast for both motion
capture and voice and all the people who worked on this game
to make it happen it's really a teamwork so just thank you
to everybody who contributed and also i want to extend a
thank to the unsung heroes of this industry the people who
make tutorials on youtube on how to make a game because we
had no idea how to make a game before so what the fuck that
has to be a joke right and i'll extend a personal thank you
to an important man in my life, Mr. Hiro-Lonobu Sakaguchi,
who is before you know this game.
It's not a joke.
It inspired me to become a game there, so thank you, Mr.
Sakaguchi.
Guys, I don't think that was a joke, guys.
That's crazy.
Go, bro, drop the videos.
Maybe I can make the next clear.
Thank you to the players for all your covers, your fan arts,
your endless arguing about which ending is a good one.
That's a wonderful trade.
Thank you so much.
And I think that actions are worth more than words.
we promised some content a few months ago.
So I'm very happy to say that it's releasing now.
Oh!
And you can just go and play it free.
New weapons, new quests, new bosses, just the cool stuff.
So just thank you so much.
Oh, but the game is not free.
It's really wonderful.
So thank you and for those who come after.
Everybody's going to boot up that game now.
That's crazy.
And you literally...
The free DLC.
Congratulations to Sandfall.
That game should be on sale right now.
And that is going to do it for the Game Awards 2025.
There's no way!
They ended it with that trail.
And teams who debuted in new games tonight.
We'll see you again on Friday, June 5th.
Our biggest summer game fest ever from the Dolby Theater in
LA.
We'll be back right here at Peacock Theater for the Game
Awards next to December, thanks to our entire game.
I don't know.
I thought it was so psych.
Happy holidays.
Good night, everybody.
There's no way they ended it with that.
Yeah, but they ended it with free game, Doki.
You're right.
The game is going to be free, guys.
The game's going to be free.
I mean, Miss Biggie warned us.
The dog warned us, guys.
That's, I think, three hours.
This was a...
That was three hours.
Oh, three, three, three and a half hours.
The longest Game Awards stream.
With the least amount of content I've ever seen.
Yeah.
At least, dang, at least the stream was fun, guys.
At least we had fun together.
You know, at least, at least we had fun together, guys.
That's, that's, that's all.
At least we were here together, chat.
Liquid, thank you for the Twitch Prime, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 100 bitties.
Patreus, thank you for the 500 bitties.
Thank you.
Look at you believing shit.
That's what you get for having hope.
Um, well, James, I'm excited for.
Um, Star Wars?
I don't know what you want me to say, guys.
We all saw the same stream.
I guess the hero guard.
Guys, it's from the same desk as Titanfall and Apex, guys.
And it's free.
We're not losing anything from it.
Oh, sorry.
The high guard.
It looked like a hero shooter, okay?
It looked like a hero shooter.
The high guard and Star Wars.
I mean, Pod Racing looked really...
cool too even though we didn't get any gameplay footage and
it's pod racing um yeah i mean i'm back my team seems fine
um i don't know if i sounded weird or not because after
getting a tooth extracted uh by the way for those who don't
know that's why i haven't been streaming for a while i got i
i i had my dentist oh yeah my i was originally gonna have a
dentist appointment on cancelled on me because they got sick
so then they're like we gotta you gotta keep your second uh
you got you can keep your second they still kept my second
appointment so they're like well the dentist for your second
appointment is still like available so you can just go on
Tuesday so I had my dentist appointment on Tuesday um so I'm
now missing one tooth people kept thinking it was like my
front teeth but it's my very back molar tooth the second
molar like the furthest top left
So, it's very weird to sometimes, when I'm in the zone,
it's, like, you know, I'm not aware of it, but when, like,
you know, when I get hyper-fixated on the missing tube, I'm
trying not to touch it and everything, because I don't want
a dry socket, which apparently it's like, because, like, you
know, there's a hole in my socket right now where my tube
should be, and, um, and so if you accidentally poke the
blood clot that's, like, blocking the hole, it will be very
painful.
So I'm like trying not to do that and have yet to do that
yet.
So yeah So let's hope let's hope that that doesn't happen.
No monkey paw curl here So I'll tell more about the story
the dentist story on YouTube because like I don't want to
put it on the random Twitch pod so I'll give you guys more
about the story on YouTube because don't worry I have a huge
story to tell you guys when I'm back It's nice to be back
again because I really did miss streaming.
I try not to push myself too hard I really wanted to stream
a lot more, but I knew Too freak like, you know, mouth
recovery takes a while So I'm trying not to push myself too
hard, but I do miss streaming.
I do miss all you guys I always love like, you know, hanging
out with you guys dragons.
I hope you guys miss hanging out with me too and had a lot
of fun Today watching the streamer awards.
I'm sorry not streamer watching the game awards.
There's been so many award shows This might as well feel
like the streamer awards.
To be fair, the streamer awards had more content than the
game awards, if I have to be honest.
Anyway, to Juarez, thank you for tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
May, thank you for the 300 bitties.
These 300 bits were for Titan and Paul.
three um anyway um what was i gonna say um but yeah no i i
really want to catch up with all you guys soon about like my
adventures uh with the dentist i felt like i was just not
online for a week because of my tooth issues uh you know how
like my gums were swollen for a week and then like you know
got my tooth removed because they were like it's not say
salvageable and i was like oh okay
Rukinat, that very expensive Rukinat guy was apparently not
worth it.
I could have just removed that tooth.
Snell, thank you for your one-sub.
Thank you.
Sankas, thank you for the gifted one-sub to Rashi.
So yeah, I was practically like non-existent for a week, and
then I came back to social media.
I'm like, what the fuck happened here?
I'm just like pro stuff, but I'm like, anyway, game awards
time.
Anyway, I'm going to head off now.
Like I said, I don't want to push myself too hard today for
recovery.
Tomorrow I have the Hades.
I'm not going to be doing a fucking 10-hour stream for Hades
2 tomorrow because I do have my May Cafe.
Mean and greet slash live performance with Mint tomorrow as
well.
And that is also like a two-hour thing.
So, and I have to sing too.
I don't know how singing is going to be like with this.
So we're going to find out.
We're going to find out.
I know.
Pretty bad timing with everything.
But I felt like it'd be worse if I had a swollen, you know,
like if I delayed my tooth extraction until after the maid
cafe because my gums were swollen.
Like I'm not delaying that shit.
So we'll see how it goes tomorrow.
So hey, do you see?
tomorrow might not be too long of a stream just because I
want to make sure I have enough time for the maid cafe stuff
similar with Saturday and Sunday um I do have like Saturday
I have a apex not apex sorry I have the rivals sorry it's
because of Titanfall 3 I'm sorry it's because of what's it
called the high god um I have the rivals tournament and then
um after rivals tournament I have the maid cafe thing again
but this is time it's a two block shift so it's not a it's a
two don't that game stop i want to forget it um and then
sunday is also the rivals tournament as well so it's like
it's sort of busy but also trying to make sure i don't fuck
myself up with talking too much um anyway guys oh you guys
enjoyed hanging out with me i always enjoy hanging out with
you guys that's been a fun fun fun game award stream watch
along um as uh for those who are new here My name is Doki
Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
So please check me out there.
Exclamation point socials.
I usually announce whenever I go live on Twitch, on Twitter.
So follow me on Twitter.
If you want to know whenever I go live on Twitch, you want
to support me via OtterMys, feel free to check out my merch.
I have a lot of merch stuff going on right now.
It's a great way to support me as well.
Thank you for all the subs, the followers, the bitties, the
support.
I really do appreciate it, guys.
It means a lot for all the support that you guys always give
me.
Obviously, I can't do this without your support.
So, thank you, guys.
Anyway, I'm going to head off now.
As always, everybody, say hi, during the posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
I don't know who I'm going to raid.
We'll find out.
Bye-bye.
I also need to feed Dad, too.
That's why he's been barking.
But he's on my lap right now.
So, I mean, he's on my lap here.
You couldn't see.
He's just, like, sleeping.
That's why he was barking a lot.
Anyway, bye-bye.
Bye!